- Bu de bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
- Ski di bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
- Ah!
- We all good?
Recording audio?
- No, we're not good.
Something's wrong with us.
- Go ahead Garnt, do the intro.
(intro music plays)
- Good evening mouth breathers.
I am your host for today.
(co-hosts laugh)
- Oh my God
- I am your host for
today nose breather Garnt.
And today are my fellow nose
breathers Connor, and Joey,
as you can see, they
love my intro right now.
- I actually did.
(Garnt laughs)
- That was like a me-you dude.
- I know right?
I'm just like
how can I make the most
Joey intro of all times?
- Just like every convention of interest.
Throw that out the window.
Just make some shit up.
- Yeah.
So how are you boys been?
- Good.
- Sweaty.
- Moist.
- It is still very hot.
We've talked about summer already,
but it is still very hot.
Very moist.
It's still very.
- This feels like a conversation
with my fucking dad.
- I know right?
I'm just like, oh, I got to.
I have to talk about the weather
before we jump into a conversation
(co-host laughs)
All is well yeah, by the
way you're dying granddad,
but how is the weather though?
(all laugh)
This feels like that warming us up
for the Trash Taste Episode.
- 'Cause I feel like when you're British,
the first thing you want to do
is just talk about the weather, right?
Or just complain about the weather.
That's just part of British culture.
- Yeah.
- It's I don't know why
it's like everywhere
- because the weather is shit in the UK?
- I feel like it's a test.
It's like, oh, are we going to socialize
in the normal capacity
of the British standards?
When talk about British
people for the first time
okay, I'm good, I know what
I can talk about and do now.
- Or are we getting super deep?
- Yeah I get it.
Cause if they come at me with
something like way left field,
I'm like, you're a weirdo.
I gotta think about what's
kind of coming next.
- It's like the only icebreaker
that's acceptable in British culture.
If they're saying you're
having a nice day,
I think I'm talking to a psychopath.
If they just asked me how the
weather is, I'm like, okay,
I can, I can engage in
a minimal conversation.
- Oh even that's a left field like intro?
I thought we were going super like
Oh so the price of gold
recently is skyrocketing.
- I think you have to understand
the sheer amount of skepticism
that British people have
like asking how your day
is, is like, is it good?
And then you're asking if something's good
and no it's not.
- It's like trick question.
- You're British.
(Joey laughs)
So inherently it's not good.
So you know asking how someone's day was
and expecting any other
response than, "oh, it's okay."
- Yeah.
- Is, is you know reasonable.
- And when I say you start
off talking about the weather,
you never compliment the weather.
It could be the best they ever,
your British people will
find something wrong with it.
You know?
"Oh, it's a bit breezy today innit."
And it's just like fucking
25 degrees outside you know,
which is very hot in
British terms by the way.
Now that I'm out there, it's
perfect temperature, but yeah.
How have you, what have you
guys been up to this past week?
- Something's been on my mind, gentlemen,
- What?
- I want to ask you.
Cause I was thinking
about this last night,
I was turning over my bed wondering,
- Really?
- Just, oh geez.
I was like, I was like,
do I have a weird opinion on this or not?
So do you read fan mail?
- No.
- Honest answer.
- Honest answer?
- No.
- Okay, okay.
You didn't have to say it like that Joey.
Just like, those fucking fans!
No!
- Wait, wait, wait, let me rephrase that.
It depends. Okay.
(co-hosts laugh)
- I don't want to sound like an asshole.
- No, no, no.
Because a lot of fan mail I get is just
sometimes you get really weird fan mail.
And we have GeeXPlus for a reason right?
It's to filter out the like the, uh.
- Are you talking like physical fan mail?
Are you talking like emails?
- Both, both.
- Okay. Well I read physical letters.
Obviously.
- You get physical letters?
- Well sometimes I do. Yeah.
- How do you get physical letters?
How do they know where to send it to?
- I don't know, they just
send it to GeeXPlus I guess.
- Oh my god.
Oh god.
- But like even like back
during like the convention
days and stuff like that,
if it's handwritten right,
then of course I'm going to
take the time to read it.
Cause you know, they
put some time into it.
Anyone can write up an email
in five seconds. Right?
So it's like, you know,
emails, it's different story.
- If it's more than like two
paragraphs, then I'll read it.
Just to see what's going on.
- You know, I was thinking about this.
Cause I remembered this whole thing
that happened a long time ago
with this YouTuber I knew.
And it was this whole stupid drama.
And you know, one of the
points that this guy proud,
prided himself on was the fact that
he responded to every
single fan mail he got.
- Okay?
- Now, when you hear that as a viewer,
you're probably thinking that's amazing.
- Yeah, what an amazing guy.
- That's great.
As a YouTuber when I hear that, I'm like,
oh, he's a psychopath.
- Yeah.
- That guy's bad news.
(Connor laughs)
That's sounds so bad as a viewer I know.
But this is like, this is
honestly one of the biggest
- Yeah that's honest to God.
- It is, like if you're a YouTuber,
you know that it depends
on how big he is. Right?
Because you reach a point as
a YouTube where you're like,
I'm going to reply to every comment and
be thankful to everyone.
- I'm gonna read all the comments.
- Which like, obviously we're
thankful to our viewers,
but you get past the point
where it becomes unmanageable
to respond to everyone.
- Yeah. Which is why it's
like the thing of, you know,
I'm not saying that, oh,
you can't check them.
You can check them right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But like people who are so proud
about the fact that they
keep up with so much of it,
it's like, you know, you have to wonder
you're like that isn't healthy for anyone
keeping up with that amount of,
- No, no.
I mean, let's just be honest.
I mean, most of it's praise, right?
- Yeah.
- And I feel like when someone
is so into hearing about,
you know, "oh God, I love
reading all these letters
of people thanking me."
I'm like,
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You're just a massive narcissist
- Yeah, well yeah.
(Garnt laughs)
- At the end of the day
what you like reading
is you like reading hundreds
and hundreds of letters
of people saying how amazing you are
- Yeah.
- Or how much they like your stuff.
- And like, I guess, you know,
self-confidence aside all right like,
it gets to a point where it's like, Hmm.
- Even when I got like
loads of physical letters,
like there was only so many
I could read in the day
before I got like,
- Overwhelmed?
- I felt like I was doing a
disservice to the letters,
just reading them all in a sequence.
Cause I'm like, all right,
now I'm, now I'm doing
what my human brain does.
And just spotting patterns.
And I'm spotting patterns
between the letters
and I'm, and I'm forming a baseline.
- You start to get numb to it right?
- Yeah you do, and I
don't like the fact that
it kind of ruins fan mail for you
that you read it so much.
- I agree with that, yeah.
- But I was having this
thought and I'm like, I was,
I was thinking about it and I'm like, huh,
I don't think I've ever
seen YouTubers who are like,
I don't fucking read any of my fan mail.
I don't read any of my fan
mail or anything like that
because people are scared to say it,
but I guarantee 90% of
the YouTubers out there
don't read their fan mail.
(Joey laughs)
- I know it sounds bad.
- Exposed!
- And this is one of those
topics that I'd love.
This is why I like Trash Taste.
Cause we can talk about this. Right?
And we can kind of come
at it from an angle
where I can kind of explain
it in a way where it's like,
I hope that I don't
come off as the asshole
- Right.
- Because it certainly
sounds like it. (laughs)
- I mean it, I feel, yeah.
No, I get it.
It's definitely a topic that as a YouTuber
you're kind of scared touch on right.
- Because a lot of the people.
And I know this is so anecdotal,
but you know, I do see the line there
and the connection there
where I've met, I've met
a lot of YouTubers who,
you know, they've uh, few
of them are fallen off now.
A few of them still do it, whatever.
But you know, they, they
prided themselves on it.
One interacting with their fans
and two, read all the fan mail
and read all the comments.
- Interacted, how so?
- Well that's, okay because
that's a whole nother thing.
- Yeah right?
- I don't trust YouTubers who
spend all their day,
in their Discord interacting
with their community.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right?
- Yes.
- That's one of the
biggest red flags to me
as a YouTuber that I don't
really wanna interact.
- I'm just like, one,
how'd you find the time to do this?
Because you have to find the time.
Basically if your interacting
too much with your community
and reading fan mails and stuff,
and then doing YouTube on top of that,
that to me says
you have no time to do
anything else in your life.
I barely have enough time to
do anything else in my life.
I had to cut this down a lot
just to make it manageable.
- Yeah. Because, when I
had my Discord in the start
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You know, it can be a
very intoxicating feeling
to feel like, "oh wow,
everyone's here for me."
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Look at all these people
wanting to talk to me,
I'm so popular.
I've never had this before, you know?
Cause you know,
you cut back a year or two before this
and I'm the guy who can barely
get four people to turn
up to a fucking event.
You know what I mean? Like.
So you kind of get intoxicated on this,
like almost narcissistic
tendency of the fact that
you love the fact that
everyone wants to talk to you
- Right.
- And that everyone wants to comfort you.
And again, it's, it's not,
I'm not trying to slate the
viewers or I'm trying to,
- It's completely
different from my Discord.
- Yeah, well this is
- I'm a fucking clown in my Discord.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- This private versus, even then. Okay.
- Yeah.
- Even though your, your
Discord is private, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- They still want your time.
- Right?
And so that's a,
that's a really difficult juggling act
because you have to separate yourself
to a certain extent to be able to,
you know, have a healthy
relationship with it
because you know, I could
talk about this forever,
but like there's, there's
differences of audiences as well.
- We've got time don't worry.
(co-hosts laugh)
- We do, we do.
- Maybe we can.
- I wanna stick on one topic for now,
but I will go into that because
there's a whole nother
thing between the difference
between male audiences, female audience
Which is kind of what
we touched on before.
- Oh God. Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And they have totally
different things, but yeah.
Going back to the whole Discord
and interacting and stuff.
So yeah, there's, there's
two kinds of interacting.
There's reading fan mail and all that.
Where to me reading the
whole fan mail thing
is a very one-sided. (giggles)
- Thank you, thank you very much Ashley.
- A one sided
- For my Trash Taste coffee.
- Fuck!
(all laugh)
- I'm trying to get in the
middle of something here Garnt.
Fuck you!
- 29.99 Plus shipping.
Get it now.
- Yeah at trashtastemugs.com
- I'ma drink water, you
know while you promote.
- Go, go ahead Connor.
Go ahead. Go ahead.
- [Ashley] I'm sorry can I get that?
- Oh my God.
(Garnt laughs)
- The Trash Taste mug?
29.99 Plus shipping.
- You know, I dunno.
Cause I just sat there and I thought, man,
this is so hard to bring up
talking about the fact that you
don't read fan mail and
not sound like an asshole.
- Wait, wait.
What got you onto this thought process?
Did something happen?
- Because I was just
thinking back and I had this,
that moment of realization
you get in the movies
and I've thought about this a lot.
And I just remember this like I said,
I remembered this situation
with this YouTuber
who I had kind of a weird interaction with
and I didn't really like him.
And I always thought he was quite strange.
- Yeah.
- And one thing that he
did that was just bizarre
is that he's one of those
YouTubers who made like
500 parts of opening fan mail.
And on one part, I
understand because I did this
because for a little
while I felt guilty that
people were sending this stuff
and they weren't getting to
see my reaction to their stuff.
- Right.
- But also once you,
once I got three episodes into doing this,
I realized, okay, well
there's only so many different ways
I can react to these fan mail.
- [Co-Hosts] Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
Like this, you know,
and some of these stories
that people would send you
are so deep and really
intense, you know, and not,
not to take away from any of them,
but some of them would
be really fucking deep.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like, very emotionally exhausting.
- And I think that it
especially feels weird
to like share that on video.
- Feels, one it feels weird
to share them on camera.
And also, you know, as
a YouTuber I'm thinking
when they wrote this story out,
you know, what do they want from me?
what did they expect when
they wrote this story?
- Like do they want a
response or something right?
- Like what kind of
response that they want.
And also, you know,
is it impractical for
me to write back now,
occasionally I'm saying this now
I'm probably gonna never do this again,
because this is probably going to be,
because I don't want people
to take advantage of this.
Occasionally when people did
send me like really touching
things to my email, you know,
all very like emotional things.
I would reply and just be like.
Hey man, keep your head up or whatever.
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I would do that.
But I didn't want to advertise
that I was doing that
because I didn't want people to think
that if they sent me a sob story,
I would reply being like,
"Hey champ, pick yourself up.
You know, here's a 10 bucks fuck off."
(all laugh)
You know what I mean? But you know,
- You didn't want to like
sell yourself as the therapist right?
- No. 'Cause you know,
when you start doing the fan
mail stuff more often than not,
I find that it does come to that.
Cause that's just how it is. You know,
people realize you respond,
people start taking advantage of that.
- I think the biggest
difference between you and us.
Well, at least me,
like when you were basically
building your audiences,
that your contents,
a lot of it revolved
around fan interaction,
- Oh like 80% of it.
- Like fan calls and fan mails
and like reading fan comments
and everything like that.
And to me, I've like I dunno, how many,
how much fan mail you get,
I probably get a lot less than
what you had to go through.
So like to me,
whenever I get a really deep
story or like a really long
piece of email, a really
long email, that's when I do,
I'm able to sit down and
read it because I rarely,
rarely get one of those.
Most of the time.
It's just like, "can you
review school days please?"
- I've messaged studio
with letting them know
that you want,
- Mikasa and Eren.
Fuck.
- That's the kind of mail
I get most of the time.
So to me it's like a nice break.
Whenever I can see someone
who actually has, you know,
put effort into their fan
mail and that's that's to me,
that's why I always end up reading it.
And it does still like
mean a lot to me that, hey,
I've done something for someone
that I've never met before.
And we'll probably never meet
that doesn't matter. You know?
- I mean some of the shit just like
I got real fucked up after a while.
Cause I was just reading
this shit for hours on end.
Like it was just extremely
depressing, you know,
because I want to help everyone out there.
Who's going through shit like
that. But yeah, you know,
it's just some of the,
some of the stuff is just,
- You can't help everybody.
- Some of the stuff is like,
I don't even know where to begin.
Like what do I even do to this? You know,
like one time someone had sent
me a thing and it was this
really nice story about their dogs, right.
And it was just give me the fucking thing.
(Garnt laughs)
- You couldn't see off camera but
Ashley was just standing
with the coffees like that.
For like two minutes.
- Ashley's like, ready to go.
- While I'm just like,
Oh God, Connor's going to get on
like a really long story right now.
- Yeah, so I was like just give it,
just give it.
- You know, there was
this, there was a story.
And I remember cause it was just so,
the way they wrote it,
it was like some kind of
momentous thing, right.
Where it was just like, I
didn't know it was coming.
And so she talked about how the, you know,
these two dogs were amazing
and she's been doing a lot better.
And it was like,
it was genuine like a three
page letter and it was great.
It was like all positive.
And it was like,
"oh yeah, so I was doing
really bad in life.
I got these new support dogs to help me.
And it was amazing."
And then I can't I'm sorry.
It was so morbid.
At the end of this thing, right.
Of this thing, that's going amazingly.
She was like,
"oh, and then my dogs died
after they got hit by a truck."
And it was like, this
two thing of it was like,
"and now it's not going
so well, but I'm trying."
And I'm like, what, what, what?
I was like emotionally,
like I was like the biggest
bungee jump. It was,
it was like some kind
of Monte Python skit.
You couldn't make this up. It was.
So if this was a comedy show,
you'd have said the comedy
was impeccably timed.
This was so, and I remember it,
cause I was just like, what?
I was like, what happened?
- That had us in the first half.
- What happened?
And you can't help but
laugh because you're like,
this is so fucked!
This is so, and I felt so sorry.
I was like what is happening?
- Yeah, sometimes you just
have a moment in life where,
you don't know how to react and you just,
your first gut reaction is just to laugh.
- Just like, I had to
re-read it three times.
I couldn't believe it.
I was like, wait, what?
- I think it's just like a
nervous, like reaction right?
- Yeah!
- Where you're just like,
how do I react to this?
- You just, I never had a
writing like that before.
If this had been done in a book.
This would be like, award-winning
this caught me totally off.
I didn't even think it was going there.
It was not a single,
there was no like hint,
there was no indicator.
- Like some M Night Shyamalan shit.
- There was no, it was all great.
And I was like, what happened?
- Jesus.
- What is this?
It was like someone had written,
it was almost like she wrote
in the letter completely
in like three days.
And then waited, like two weeks
before she sent it and
then made an addendum
at the end, just being like, oh,
and by the way,
- Like a footnote.
- Yeah just being like PS, by the way,
- PS they're dead.
- PS, it's not good now.
And I'm like, what?
And then this is also,
this is just terrible.
I don't want to, it's horrible
to deal with that stuff.
- And it's like, what.
What does that person
expect you to like react?
- Yeah and so, yeah, exactly.
But you know, not to take
anything away from her,
I do appreciate her sharing
that makes obviously you know
- Very personal.
- Very emotional, right.
And in one hand, I appreciate it.
But I'm also hand when I hear
about people who are reading
tons and tons of these
letters and, and they love it.
And it's just like, what?
Like, can you emotionally
handle all of this?
And if you can, like, I have
to like, are you a psychopath?
Like, this is a, this is a lot, you know?
It's like,
imagine if you were speed
running therapy for some people
you're just like,
you get the sob story.
Then you got to get to help.
Like they just, they leave.
And it's like, this is horrible.
- Yeah. I mean and I think it's,
it's unfortunate that we
can't listen to everyone
because I got into YouTube because
I wanted to like just find other people.
- I wanna connect to people.
- Yeah I wanted to connect to people.
I wanted to find people with
the same interests that I had,
which is why, a lot of the friends
a lot of our close friends in England
that we have now
are like people I met through YouTube
or through being fans of my content.
And through that, I kind of
like for, for the longest time,
I kind of prided myself of
like, you know, if you're a fan,
come say hi, and maybe we can
be friends one day, you know,
who knows? And that was, that
was when that was manageable.
- Right.
Like some, some of my first,
some of my first fans are now like
some of my closest friends,
one of them is going to be
like one of those, like,
you know, some of them are
going to be at my wedding,
- Groomsmen, right.
- Yeah, yeah exactly.
So it's gone from that to now
like I cannot, you know, even if I'm,
even if I'm sure there are a
lot of you guys watching out
there who I know I'm probably, you know,
that we could be pretty close friends.
We're just not going to have
the opportunity for that,
unfortunately, right.
- Most likely, most likely.
- Because like, to me
- Because there's one of you.
- Because there's only one
of me and there's literally
hundreds of thousands
of you guys, and it's,
it's an unfortunate fact
that I just had to like,
make peace with and just
be like, you know, this,
this is it's part of the job is managing
kind of like my fan interaction
and just interacting
with the amount of people
you can physically and
humanly interact with
and get emotionally involved with.
- Yeah. And I guess,
and it's like that
massive difference between
someone who has come to that
realization in their career
and is able to manage it.
And some people who are just like,
"nope, if you're a fan of me,
you're not just a fan you're friend,
you can approach me at
any time," kind of thing.
But then they forget that the
larger they grow and the more
and more of those fans become
friends, quote unquote,
then it gets to the point
where they're just like,
that's just their entire life. Right.
You end up with people
like what you were saying.
- Yeah. I mean, that could have been,
- Interact with their fans 24/7.
- That could have been me you know.
- There are a lot of
YouTubers out there who have
- Still do that?
- Still or who I'd say of, you know,
at the cost of their
own channel, you know,
have continued to do it because
a lot of them get really,
I've seen the so many YouTubers
who get so sucked into their Discord.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And you know, this is why
I said it way, way back.
You know, my number one piece of advice
is to not make a Discord server.
A public Discord server.
- Which is why we haven't made
a Trash Taste Discord server.
- Even though people have asked.
- Yeah, it's my number
one piece of advice to
any YouTuber, because it's,
it's a time sink, you know,
managing a Discord server.
Luckily now I don't manage it.
I've gotten it.
I don't go on there.
- Yeah me neither.
- Like I post updates you know,
people understand it now, but you know,
I remember when I first
started stepping back from it,
I would get a lot of messages being like,
I can't believe you aren't active.
That's so wrong,
this is your Discord server.
You should be active.
It's like, why, what would you want to do?
You want me to sit here and message you?
So the other 2 million
people can't have a video.
Like you want to take
time away just so I can,
I can laugh at the meme you
sent me like kitten lord XD.
You know what am I supposed to do?
- I actually had to
coach Sydney through this
because she actually, I think she had a,
like a public Discord and
you know, at the beginning,
everyone wants to
interact with their fans.
- It's great in the start.
- It's great, it's great.
Everyone wants to interact with their fans
as much as they can.
And it got to the point
where Sydney thought
that if she didn't do it,
then people would think
that she was ungrateful
for the attention or for like
for them supporting her channel.
And I'm just like, and
she grew to a point where
she was waking up, just stressed.
She was waking up and she was like,
I've just got so many notifications.
- No, mate me too, me too.
- Yeah, yeah and it was like, she woke up
and for full like month,
I think she was just depressed
because she didn't know how
to handle everyone trying to
get a piece of her attention.
I'm just like, look,
you've got to, because,
because this was, this was back when,
like this was back when
she started to, you know,
kind of get a bit of, a bit
of momentum and so and I like,
luckily she had me to coach
her through it because I,
- Literally had like a perfect coach.
- Cause I was just like, look,
you've gotta just get
past this point where
you've just gotta realize
that it is part of the job.
And part of the job is just
understanding that you can't
give everyone attention.
I know you want to,
I know it kills you to show
everyone how grateful you are
for their support and everything.
But it's physically
impossible for one person
at a certain size.
- Yeah. Like if someone meets
me in person and you know,
if they want to speak to me,
I'll gladly speak to
you at any, we'll talk.
And I would rather that so much more
than a message through
the screen. I don't know.
It literally doesn't mean anything
when you're messaging through it.
Like Discord, if you
don't know the person,
I don't even know who you are.
Like Thanos over here, bro.
I don't know what's going on.
- Honestly I think like the
best way to just have a casual
conversation, is it, I
mean, you can't plan it,
which is unfortunate, but if
it's mostly conventions, right.
If you see us at a party at
a convention or just like
hanging out,
we look like we're just not
heading somewhere or like busy,
then we'll probably have time to like,
have like a quick chat or something.
- I'd love to man.
(group affirmation)
That's why I wanna go to conventions.
- The quick chats are
always the best I think.
- and sometimes you meet an
interesting character and you're
just like, yeah, we should hang out later.
You know at like one of the parties
that we're going to or
something like that.
- I've had people where I'm like, yo come.
- Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
- It'll be fun.
- Right. Yeah.
Yeah. But like, you know,
unfortunately that's just
not something you can plan,
you know, we're going to
obviously going to find it creepy,
if they're going to be like,
"okay, so this person can
be here, at this convention,
and he's going to be
here, here, here, here.
I can say hello here.
And hopefully,"
- Just like corkboard it out.
"All right hear me out,
he's gonna be here, so we have
to rendezvous right here."
(all laugh)
- 'Cause like I've had a really
weird kind of like strange
evolution of like interactions.
Now that Trash Taste has started, right.
Because obviously the
world hasn't opened up yet,
but I've now met like a few
people post Trash Taste that has
just been like,
so like we've met in like
a normal social situation.
So it's just been like at a
friend's party or at like some
kind of gathering, but they're like,
"yeah, I watch Trash Taste."
And the first thing they say is,
"look, I know about the
para-social relationship thing,
but like, I'll just say it upfront.
And like,
I understand that there's
like a difference between
knowledge between what I know about you
and what you know about
me." And I'm just like,
this is actually really weird
because I think that's the
best way to handle it. Just,
just like acknowledging that.
Yeah.
They're an active viewer
and they know more about
me than I do about them so,
- Yeah just in meeting them
they're like, I might like you,
but I know you're not my friend.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I'm just like, I'm just like, cool.
Let's close that gap then.
- Did you see the clip of
Felix talking about it?
- No.
- Someone asked out loud,
"do you know Connor?"
He's like, "yeah I do."
He was like "I watch Trash Taste.
It's weird. I feel like I know them,
but I don't know them at all."
- God that coming from Felix.
My god! (laughs)
- Felix was like "I feel weird.
I feel like that my friends,
but I've never spoken to them."
(all laugh)
I would say that's great.
Felix is saying that, I
was like, that's the best.
- That's the thing though,
if Felix is saying that
then fucking everyone
is susceptible to it right.
- Yeah so you can't, don't feel guilty.
- Don't feel guilty.
- The big boss man himself
feels it. It's all right.
- The thing I'm trying
to say is we don't know
how to handle it correctly.
As much as you don't know
how to handle it correctly,
we're all fucking in this together.
- It's a very strange situation
we've all found ourselves in.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But like, that's, that's why I'm,
I'm also glad that we are quote
unquote like famous on the
internet because like, you
know, because like that's,
that's why, like,
if there's one group of people
who are fucking sociopath's
it's fucking papparazzi, right.
Cause if you've seen any
interview or just any documentary
or any story following the paparazzi,
they're fucking nutcases.
- The fucking Anthony Padilla video.
Like that still blows my mind to this day.
Just like hearing just the
audacity of some of these guys
just being like, yeah, I don't give a fuck
if the opportunity is there, I'll take it,
I'm like what the fuck?
- Because one thing I'm thankful for
is that because we've grown
up in an age where I think a
lot of our viewers are more
aware of, you know, what
it's like and you know,
social boundaries and stuff like that
because we have places like
Trash Taste to talk about it,
but fucking celebrities
back in the day, they,
they didn't have this,
you know, they were,
they were basically put on
a pedestal and kind of like
almost looked at like a
commodity and you can do anything
you wanted to celebrity.
You can break all kinds
of social boundaries.
And it was acceptable back in the day.
And that's why papparazzis
were able to do what the,
whatever the fuck they did right.
- It was just that like
weird stigma of like,
oh, you are famous.
Therefore you are open to any criticism.
You are open to just getting
your entire private life
exposed by anyone at any time.
And you have no right to say because
that's the cost of being famous.
That's like bullshit.
- That is bullshit.
- Like it's complete bullshit.
- I remember one time I saw a
clip of Toby Maguire trying to
like trying to just, just
go out of his driveway
and just go wherever
he wanted to that day.
And he just got swarmed
by paparazzi right.
And so the paparazzi literally
were just in front of his car,
trying to look, like a
group of locusts, right.
Trying to like snap this
picture of Toby Maguire.
And he like moves out slowly.
And he's just like trying
to politely say, "excuse me,
can you, can you guys get out of the way?
Can you guys get out of the way?"
They don't go out of the way
he moves an inch and he
goes, "excuse me, can you,
I'm just trying to get out of my driveway.
Can you guys get out of my
driveway?" And they don't move.
And then he, of course
like any human being,
he fucking gets angry and
he loses it and he goes,
"dude move out of the fucking driveway!
I'm just trying to get out!"
And then the paparazzi's like,
"wow, what an asshole."
And I'm just like what?
How up your own arse you need to be
to have this kind of mentality right?
- Guaranteed the moment
he started screaming,
all the paparazzi just
simultaneously started drooling,
being like, "that's a story right there.
Let's go!"
- Which is why this clip
got posted out right.
- No one respects the paparazzi anyway.
So it doesn't, it doesn't fucking matter.
- No.
- Yeah. In terms of like
the social hierarchy,
I believe they're like below
fucking like dung beetles man,
like honestly, zero respect for paparazzi.
- I mean people would rather
cockroaches in their apartment
than paparazzi.
- Probably, probably.
- Oh yeah, 100% yeah.
- I guess, take that one
how you will, but yeah.
- Exactly.
- But yeah, I mean, going
back earlier to the whole,
you know, giving attention,
I think, you know,
like I remember one thing
that people would say.
And they would like, they
would praise you if you would,
if you would interact with
your viewers, it'd be like,
"wow, this is so refreshing. You know,
big YouTubers is don't
talk to their audience."
And at the time when you,
when you have like 50K subs
that probably gets to your
head, what do you think?
Yeah, I am, I'm doing great.
Like I'm why can't these people
interact with their fans.
So fun. This is great.
This is going amazingly.
And then you realize all you
should realize shortly after
why that is a bad idea, because
then you have no free time.
Like I remember specifically,
- Then your content starts to deplete.
- Well, yeah, I remember
I would spend like
at least two to three
hours a day on my Discord,
like answering messages,
keeping up with the
server, just doing that.
And I'm like two to three hours
a day on what? Like on what.
- 'Cause the problem is it
slowly creeps up on you, right?
- Yeah.
- At first it was like
15 minutes of your day.
You just get 15 minutes, 15
minutes where you feel happy.
You're like, oh, people, people like me,
people like people like
what I do. That's great.
And then like it slowly,
like five minutes gets
added on like in a month.
And then you do content for
two years and suddenly you're
wasting two hours of your days.
You have two hours just gone.
- Yeah.
- And then, you know, also, you know,
someone gets banned from the
server and if you're active on
the server, you definitely
get the complaint for the,
the reasoning. You know,
one thing that I noticed when
I was on the server was that
every goddamn week someone
would come to you and be like,
"my friend unjustly
got banned and this is,
Connor's a dickhead.
Connor's a piece of shit.
He banned my friend for no reason."
You check the log,
the guy who said like the
N word, like 10 times.
And he's like, what?
Like what, what are you on?
- It's just words bro.
- What are you on?
- It's just words.
- Is this how it feels to be YouTube?
(all laugh)
When they take down a video.
- Like, this is why I
feel sorry for YouTube,
this is how they feel sometimes,
someone uploads like a titty or something.
like, what do you mean bro?
(Connor imitates angry YouTuber)
- "I can't believe YouTube
banned me, what an asshole."
- Yeah, and it's, you know,
when the Discord server starts its great
and when you have to actually
moderate a Discord server,
that's where it gets hell.
And then you know that, you know,
when you bring a
moderators, you know, some,
sometimes I remember my
moderators sort of sometimes start
like in fighting and I'm
like, what the fuck is this?
What is this?
I'm just trying to,
I'm just trying to make a
server where I can thank my fans
and now it's turned into a whole,
you know, House Of Cards-esque situation
what the is going on here?
What the fuck is going on?
And there's just so many downsides to it.
And I just, it's such a,
it's such a complex situation
and feeling if you haven't experienced it,
it's so hard to think about
all the possibilities of stuff
that comes up because I didn't
think about any of this shit.
And even when I was in the
middle of it, I didn't know what,
what could go wrong, you know.
- Hey everyone, it's me, Joey.
And just Joey, the
other boys are not here,
but I'm here to tell you about
the sponsor for today's video
Express VPN.
Internet service providers know
every single website you visit
and ISPs can sell this information.
Ad companies and tech giants,
who then use your data to target you.
You don't want to be targeted.
I don't want you to be targeted.
And that's why Express VPN is here a baby.
Express VPN creates a
secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet.
So your online activity can't
be seen by anyone it's as easy
as closing the bathroom door.
You just fire up the app
and click one button and
you are fully protected.
Plus Express VPN is rated number one
by CNN and Tech Radar.
And it works on phones,
laptops, even routers,
every way you share your
wifi can be protected.
I use express VPN to watch
anime on Crunchy Roll because
Crunchy Roll is blocked in Japan.
I can't believe they
would do that to your boy.
So you can secure your online
activity today by going to
expressvpn.com/trashtaste
That's E-X-P-R-E-S-S vpn.com/trashtaste
to get three months of
Express VPN for free
back to the episode.
- Do you guys still read YouTube comments.
- First day Yeah.
Yeah, first day.
I kind of, I kind of
want to get the consensus
of the feeling from the viewers.
Cause I feel like the people
who watch on the first day
are the core audience.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And those are the people I care about
hearing about the most, you
know, I want to know what my,
the people who watch
my video day one think.
Cause you know,
when the video starts doing really well
and it goes outside of your audience
that's when you get really weird comments.
- Yeah.
- You know, like uh.
- The ones that turn into not English.
- Yeah, so like my Rent-A-Boyfriend
video like blew up.
I knew, I knew it was going to do well
because it's very good clickbait.
Like you see that and like.
- Yeah I saw that and I'm just like this,
this is going to be a banger.
- Even if the video was me,
even if the video was me
just going to a Denny's and
just texting a guy and saying I rented it.
I'm sure the video would have
done a million views anyway,
because thumbnail and
the title is so good.
- Yeah well, yeah yeah.
- And like I said, I knew it would.
So there's some of the
comments that were on it
that were just like what the fuck?
what the fuck are these?
And it's like, "Ew is he gay?
Is man gay?"
(all laugh)
- Is man gay?
- Its like and just weird stuff.
Like, "I bet he smells nice"
and all that kind of stuff.
And just, you just start to get like
the really strange comments coming out.
So I don't really give a
shit about them, but yeah,
definitely day one, I check.
Sorry, I went on a whole
explanation about that.
- No.
- No, no, no yeah, like, yeah,
For me as well, day one is
kind of like the consensus
of like, again, it's like,
it's the ones who are subscribed to you
its the ones that's always
waiting for your video.
So it's like, you know, usually
I also don't just look at
the top comments either.
I always look at it from a new.
- New, newest yeah, you can't,
you can't always look at the top comments
because those are the ones, like,
if there's anything with
constructive criticism,
it's going to be buried down somewhere.
And I want to, those are
the ones I want to find.
- The most liked ones are usually
some kind of meme that
came out of the video.
- Or quote from the video.
- Or a quote from the
video and yeah, I get it.
We all, we all watched the video.
- The problem is,
is that I actually don't
want to check the comments
half the time
because I don't want to
check my YouTube analytics.
- Yeah. That's me too.
I literally click on the video.
I'm just like, don't,
don't show me the views.
Don't show me the views.
- So to check the comments
on the YouTube app
on the studio YouTube studio app.
The first thing that pops
up when you open this app
is your views, how the video is doing
and the amount of money you're
earning and all that stuff.
I don't want to see that stuff.
- And the elusive something out of 10.
- We've talked about that
(group mumbling agreement)
- I don't, I don't want to know
how my video is doing every day.
Counterintuitively I probably should care.
You know, any expert in
analytics would tell you
that you should be checking
it and studying it.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I've been doing YouTube
for like five years
off pure gut feeling.
And I think I'm doing all right.
I think, I think I
understand what's going on.
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So I don't, I don't
want to look at that.
I don't care how much
it's making. I don't,
I don't care how many
views it's getting. I just,
I just want to read the comments.
I don't check it that often
because I have to see that shit.
- Yeah.
- So I kind of.
- For me, it's just like, is it monetized?
Good. I don't need to see anything else.
I'm satisfied.
- Yeah. I'd say check every
two to three days now.
- Really?
- Just like once yeah.
- Yeah. Cause I think I
checked on the first day
and then that's just it,
like, I just check, is this
are people enjoying this video?
That's all I need to know.
And then I just kind of leave it at that.
But I remember before, when
I first started, you'd like,
that was a full fucking week. Right.
I call it the honeymoon
period where you were just,
you were so proud of this
video and you just like kept
refreshing the comments and
you're just like, come on,
there must be a new comment.
There must be new comment.
And I like that, like that,
that period was like a full-on
week for me before, when I,
when I released a video.
And then the longer you
do YouTube, the lower,
the lower that honeymoon
period is until like,
it's like, it's different.
Because if you're really,
if I'm really, really proud of a video,
I'm still like checking
more comments than,
than like some other videos, for example.
And I was wondering like,
is it the same for you guys?
Or is it just like the
same for every video now?
Like how much do you guys
see YouTube as a job?
Is it just like a completely a job now?
- I mean, I'd be lying if I
said its no longer a hobby.
- It is no longer a hobby.
- Yeah it's no longer a hobby at all.
- I mean if it wasn't for,
I think the job is what makes
me have to upload weekly.
I wouldn't upload weekly
if it was on my own back,
I think I would do once a month.
Cause I love like some videos.
I absolutely adore making,
like, there's this one
video that has been in the,
I can't talk about it yet,
but it's been in the works.
A lot of approvals.
A lot of, a lot of things
have had to have been done
to get this video done.
- Yeah.
- But I'm hoping that when it comes out,
it's gonna be amazing.
And it's been like a
passion project for a while.
And that, that's just like
saying that I would've done.
Yeah you know, regardless, like,
even if it didn't make any money,
even if it wasn't my job,
like I would've made that
like regardless like nothing.
And so that's amazing when you get that,
but that only comes around I feel like
twice a year at most,
you get like a truly,
- At most yeah.
- A truly passionate, really amazing idea.
And everything seems
to be kind of working.
You know, you get all
the approvals you want,
you get all the, go aheads,
you get all the, you know,
cause you know, especially now it's, we,
we do a lot of filming
outside of our house
in Japan need a lot of approval stuff.
It takes a long time.
Before it was just kind of like
how many hours can I put in on this thing
now it's become the case of
can I get the right approval.
- Because sometimes you just
have to have a passion project
that was like, I think I was me in like
the Fate timeline I did.
Cause like how, when, when
did I first mention that?
- A year ago.
- Like over a year ago
and it just got released
like a few weeks ago.
- Yeah.
Cause I'm just like,
- is that a passion
project or a job? Sorry.
- Oh, that was a passion project.
Cause I'm just like do really people are,
do people really want to hear
someone explain Fate for 30 minutes?
- Answer, yes.
- But like I had so much fun
filming that and I'm just like,
this is just a fun thing to work on.
- Yeah.
- I think everyone enjoyed it
except for the Fate community
for some reason they
sort of got salty about.
- Oh yeah.
- I mean, I mean like
you gotta, you gotta,
you gotta take, you gotta
take it with a grain of salt
sometimes being an anime YouTuber,
you can very much piss off a lot of
different anime fandoms
it's you know, it's to me,
it's part of the job right
because I feel like, you know,
I feel like with you, you're more of like
a personality with like who
sells himself on just, you know,
I'm a guy living in Japan
and I like anime. Right.
Whereas I think me and Joey
have had our fair share
of experiences where,
because we maybe say our opinions
of an anime or maybe like
we've gotten to a point where
we can have like an effect on
the community then sometimes, you know,
sometimes people can be
unhappy with what we say.
- Unhappy is a, it's a very loose term.
- I'm being very civil with
the words I use right now.
- No, no. I mean, I I'm, I'm
your guys' friend obviously.
So I understand, you know,
where you guys are coming from and
yeah sometimes I feel
like fucking hell man.
This guy's being real harsh on you guys.
Some of these comments
so much, Jesus Christ.
You just made a video about Fate.
Shut up bro.
Chill out, why you have to be so mean?
- I mean, that's why that's like,
I'd be lying if I said like that,
wasn't one of the big reasons
why I don't make videos on
like popular or big franchises
anymore because it's like,
it doesn't matter if I'm
praising the shit out of it.
It doesn't matter if I'm
saying an unpopular opinion or
whatever the fan base is
going to get off either way,
just purely because of the
fact that I made a video on it.
- Yeah. I think, cause I
never really, I thought I,
whenever I made videos about stuff,
it was always like the kind of ah,
BL communities and they're
always just really grateful that
anyone was making videos
about that at all.
- Yeah, it's weird right? Cause like,
cause I've also like slightly
stepped into that when I made
a video on Killing Stalking
and that was one of the most like
praised by the community
videos I ever got, I was like
I though I was gonna get shat on.
- Hand to God, bro.
BL fans are like the best fans ever, man.
They are so supportive
of anyone getting into BL
in any capacity.
They'll only give a shit
If you get shit wrong,
they're just like, we're just glad
that someone's appreciating it.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Because it's so niche.
- And some of it is like amazing work
that just gets overlooked
because it's gay.
Like, I mean, you know, so it's amazing.
And you know, seeing some of
these communities, you know,
there are a lot of some
shounen communities
that get very defensive.
The Fate one.
Yeah, cause I remember
Garnt did this video.
I'll talk about it cause Garnt
doesn't want to say anything,
but other people will be so
harsh to Garnt they were like,
ah, Garnt made this video
about the Fate timeline.
Like, oh something are wrong or,
oh how dare he get, you
know, make this video
that's just terrible and
incorrect in so many ways.
I'm like bro chill out man.
And I think some of these
were the smaller YouTubers.
I think they were getting
(group chattering)
- I'm like do you want
to make a video on it?
Go ahead.
- Well, I think they have
and they were just like,
it's not as good as mine.
It's like the point is that
you have to understand is that,
you know, if you're a Fate YouTuber,
if you're a specific YouTuber
and you're going to be more
focused on the oriented details of it,
when you're a more general
YouTuber who covers more,
more topics, you know,
and you're covering a wide span of things,
you're gonna be focused on entertainment.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And I feel Garnt's
video in a lot of ways
was more entertainment based.
- When I watch Garnt
I'm not giving a shit.
I'm not watching it for Fate law.
I couldn't give a fuck.
I just want to watch something funny.
- If I wanted to see Fate
law I would go onto the Wiki.
- Yeah I want something. I want something,
- I'm just being real.
- I want something funny. You know?
So when I saw people, when
I saw people you know,
I feel like I'm just
defending my friend here.
- As we should.
- Keep, keep going.
This is, this is, this is
the rare time where we,
where we've like got
each other's back I guess
- we got you homey.
- We're not shitting
on each other for once.
I'm feeling weird right now.
It's like Connors defending me?
(Connor laughs)
- What's, what's going on?
- I saw this and I wanted that,
you know when you're gonna
hold your friend back.
You're like no, no don't do that.
I'm gonna reply because I'm like,
bro, you're missing the
entire fucking point.
It's not to make a video
that's correct about Fate.
Let's make a video that's
entertaining about Fate.
The point is that yes
it's not going to be a
hundred percent correct.
If it is fantastic,
Garnt's done a great job researching.
The point is, is that
yeah, that might annoy you,
that somebody tells it wrong
and you've put in all this hard work
and your video is not
gonna get as many views.
But by, by making a video about Fate,
you're giving an avenue for
more people to get into Fate,
which, you know, when
someone big makes a video
about something that you do,
it's great because you
get a kick down effect,
whether you like it or
not, you get that effect.
- Yeah.
- You know, there's the Fate
people who made videos about it
are gonna get views from that video,
because guess what's gonna be
recommended on a Fate video
Fate.
- Yeah.
- And it's just very, I don't know.
It's just another case of people
just wanting to take
shots at the big guys.
And I dunno, I've never
really had to deal with it.
So I'm all right. But
I feel bad for you two,
cause for some reason you
guys are like punching bags
for all the people, I don't know why.
- I mean its,
- I think it's weird because
I obviously never intended this,
but I think it's just because
we are seen as kind of,
kind of like pseudo critics or whatever.
Like I dunno, cause I don't see myself
as anything of the sort.
I just see myself as like
one guy giving an opinion.
- And I've said that so
many times with videos,
but the moment you say that
to the reviewing and critic fanbase,
they're like, oh, he's
just trying to be a critic.
He's just trying to be a reviewer.
He's trying to take out jobs.
And I'm like, no, I'm really not.
I just want to make a video on this
because I'm passionate about it.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, like I think
there's, there's two things,
especially in the anime
community because the anime
community grew up from
being like a very niche,
small community. Right?
So sometimes like sometimes
I will make a video or I will
title my video in a certain
way because I do it with the
assumption that the person
watching it knows nothing about
the topic I'm talking about.
And the thing is because
anime fans were and still are,
especially in niche communities, very,
very dedicated to whatever
niche or whatever fandom that
they are a fan of.
They get, I wouldn't say very defensive,
but at least like they are
very judgmental about what any
kind of content that gets made.
Especially like where, I
mean, we talked about Fate,
but like especially shounen community.
I don't know what it is
about shounen community.
That is, they are just so
competitive with one another.
- [Connor] They are.
- Because there's so many of them as well
in this day and age.
- Like you say, you say
an opinion, you know,
like it's just basically
impossible to have an opinion on
any, any singular shounen show.
Right. I'm not, it's, it's,
it's especially difficult.
Especially like if you just
make a tweet or something or if
you say I'm enjoying X more
than X or people, people,
people will like take
those words and be like,
what the fuck did he just say?
No fucking way!
- I remember I tweeted it
out ages ago saying like,
you know what, after all
these different manga
that I've read from like all
the popular stuff to like the niche stuff,
no one thinks about at the end of the day,
I'm always going to go
back to shounen jump.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And the shounen jump like
community got on my ass for it.
Be like I can't believe
you're discrediting,
shounen champion and
shounen Sunday and I'm like,
I literally praised you guys.
What do you want me to.
What more do you want me to say?
- But the thing I've noticed,
right, is that this is,
for some reason it's it's
for the most part only,
only contained in like
the shounen community
and the shounen culture.
Like for example,
I let's look I'm the Isekai guy, right?
So let's say guys,
I prefer ReZero over No Game No Life.
Nobody bats an eye.
I say I prefer Demon Slayer.
I say, I prefer a Demon
Slayer for fucks sake.
I say, I prefer Demon Slayer over?
Demon Slayer, Demon Slayer.
- This is such a controversial opinion
that his brain is literally stopping.
- Yeah, I'm like, my brain
is like don't say it.
- Don't say it!
- Stop, don't say it.
I say I prefer My Hero
Academia to Jujutsu Kaisen
everyone loses their mind.
I don't, by the way, that was just a,
that was just a random quote
that I just generated that
that's going to turn the internet on fire.
- But of course, someone's
going to take that
out of context and be like, I
can't believe Garnt said that.
- Yeah. I think cause nobody
respects my opinion. So.
(co-hosts laugh)
So that's kind of whenever I.
- That's what I want.
I don't want people to respect me.
- I don't want people to take
my opinion that seriously.
- Whatever I say, no
one really bats an eye.
They're like oh well I guess
Connor's never really had a
good opinion so it's whatever.
- But I want that at this point.
Like I get it that, you know.
I appreciate-
- Probably cause I've never
really criticized shows.
I just kind of say, I like it or I don't,
I've never really gone in,
I think it's when you've criticized shows,
people get the,
people start to probably in some aspects
value your opinion.
- Which, you know.
- Which is up to them.
- I respect that. I
respect in a lot of ways,
but at the same time, it's like,
there were some people
there's a difference between
respecting and understanding
and opinion and taking that
into consideration and also
basing your entire life around
that person's opinions.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You know, like even me, like I've,
I've tried to talking about anime content.
I've tried to not be so negative
or like I've tried to like
only focus on things that I do like,
and that I want to highlight. Right.
- And that's a big difference.
- No, because I didn't use to be that way.
I used to be like,
you know, I used to like clown
on a lot of shows, but now,
now I at least try to try to
just talk about things I like,
but even,
even if I've just make a quick
joke about something that
then that one line from a video
that had nothing to do with
that topic or that fandom,
that, that, you know,
that one quote gets spread
around on Twitter and spread
around everywhere.
And especially now that we stream
and we're on Trash Taste
there are people that can just
take one line out of context
from a conversation that's
not even to do with the anime
I'm talking about and just be like,
oh Garnt thinks this.
Or Garnt thinks that.
And I've,
I guess it's just something
I've had to learn to deal with
as, as my content has evolved.
- I said the exact same things as you,
I could say the exact same things as you
and nobody will bat an eye,
but the way you say it, it's
like, bro, shits going down.
- It's like, CdawgVA said an opinion.
No one cares.
- It's very strange yeah.
- Gigguk says and opinion (loud gasp)
I sure must offended that
nobody gives a what I say.
But on the other hand, I'm like, great.
If it means I don't have
to deal with this, like.
- Oh God, I wish I was you.
Well, I think,
I think part of it just
comes with time as well,
because unfortunately the longer
you are on the platform or
the internet than the more quote unquote,
like I hate calling them
haters because that just,
I just like people who
dislike you, the more,
the more people who dislike
you will slowly build up.
Cause I remember, I,
I remember when I first started
my YouTube channel and like,
I think it was like the
first five years of content.
Most of the opinions I saw
of me were mostly positive.
Right.
But then there would be one comment
that you know had a negative opinion of me
or like one small community and
the longer you're on YouTube,
the more like the more negativity
that gets built up slowly
over time, just because one,
your audience is getting bigger.
And two, a lot of times when
you get a hater or when you get
something, someone who
doesn't like your content,
they're just going to stay that way.
And they're just not going to give you
the chance or another opportunity
because they're not going to
watch your content anymore.
So that one opinion they have you
is going to remain that way
throughout the rest of
your YouTube career. Right.
So I think it's also a
thing with time as well.
Cause I think a lot of big
YouTubers who've been on this
platform for a long time have
had to deal with negativity,
building up over time. And I think,
I think there's no one that
epitomise is this more than
maybe Felix and I like,
I've never personally talked to the guy,
but from what you've said about
what you've said to you at
about how he deals with
it, it's just like,
it just seems like the most
mature way away. It's just,
it's just something you just
got to deal with. Right?
Yeah. Honestly.
- Part of the job,
- Do you find that it's possibly
a reflection of the content
you make, you know, when you're
saying it's more than that,
you're new, you're more negative focused.
Do you find that
you tend to get a more
negative response from.
- Yeah, definitely.
When you have, I mean, that's,
when you have a controversial opinion,
then you will get controversial
comments as well. Right?
- But like if you're always
saying like shows are trash
or this is bad, do you find that,
or did you find that the
viewers were more likely to be
negative about things?
Are you saying like,
are they more positive now that
you've swapped to being more
positive about shows?
- Yeah.
Definitely. Definitely
like, like one, like I.
- Cause maybe that could
be it for the difference.
- No, I mean, like, I, I, because I,
the reason I changed my
content wasn't because of only
because of that is because some
of the content creators that
I used to watch, and maybe I
watched back in the day, like,
I kind of noticed that
man being, being negative,
it's just not very fun. And sure.
There are shows that I don't like,
- It gets more views though.
It gets more views.
- Because you know,
- And that's the tough part.
- Cause you know, I remember
there was always like,
fuck what was it,
like the, The Completionist
whatever. Right.
Don't know if you've seen his channel.
- No.
- He always does like these top
tens at the end of the year,
top 10 worst and top 10 best games.
- [Garnt] Right.
And he would release
them like back-to-back
and always the top 10
worst would get more views.
- Oh yeah, all the time.
even though they were like way
lesser known titles. Right.
People just want to know
what the worst thing is.
- Yeah I mean Needle Drop does
the same thing every year.
Where its like the top 10
worst albums of the year
always did like twice the
number, of the top 10 best.
- Yeah. And if, I mean,
I feel like top 10 worst is
just better clickbait because
nobody really wants to
know the top 10 best.
Or like people are less
interested in knowing
what the top 10 best is.
They want to know what the trash is.
- Well, that's why I, when I try and be,
I try and dunk on something,
I try choose something
that's just unanimously,
- No, exactly. Right.
- Not great.
- Yeah. Which is why top 10 worst is good.
Because normally if it's like
the worst of the worst, then,
then people there's,
people won't bat an eye.
Because it's just like,
it's there to be clowned on, you know.
like I can clown on xArm all I want
and people will fucking love it.
Cause it's hilarious. I
mean, have you seen xArm?
You know, I know you have Joey.
- It's amazing, I love it.
That was great. But like,
if you, for example,
have a controversial opinion
of a popular show or a popular
thing, it's going to get a lot of views.
But I feel like in the long
- But at what cost right?
- Yeah, yeah, in the long term,
like it just, it just makes you seem
like a cynical shit head.
And did that just hates
everything. I just like,
- Not wrong.
- Even like,
even if you just make one
video about one popular show,
but just shit on it,
people are going to
remember that for years.
Right. I don't know why, but
people have such long memories.
You could, you could, you
could just make, like,
you could spend five years.
- Is there an example that
you have in your head.
One video that-
- People to this day still think
I'm like the guy who hates,
Sword Art Online, even
though I literally made what,
two videos on it,
out of the thousands of
videos I've made in my career.
- Oh yeah.
I mean,
- Even though, even though
there are so many channels,
I can think of that have done
way more videos shitting
on Sword Art Online.
And yet I'm just known as the guy.
Who's like, oh yeah, you
hate Sword Art Online, right?
I'm like, yeah.
But I'm also like all these other things.
- Did you really hate
Sword Art Online that much?
Or was it,
- I mean,
- Or did you play it out for the camera?
- Well, I guess I'll say it now.
I played it out for the camera, for sure.
- Yeah, I know you, I
know you fucking did.
- But I thought that was
pretty fucking obvious.
I made a Vegeta Review 69 video,
which is like the parody
character I made back in the day.
Right. So it's like, obviously, and again,
because back then when I was
a lot smaller and I was still
building on my channel.
- But that's what you
do when you're growing.
- That's what you have to do to grow.
- You think you have
to be this exaggerated
and you have to hate everything.
- Right, right.
- 'Cause like, I remember
YouTube, YouTube, like reviews,
I guess went through this
phase where being negative was
like the cool thing.
- Well, it was like around
when I Hate Everything
started popping up.
- Yeah like, I Hate
Everything, Nostalgic Critic,
Angry Video Game Nerd where it's just like
- Grade A Under A.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Grade A Under A.
It was just like being cynical
was like, was just cool.
You know, that was, that
was a cool thing to do.
And it was a dark period
in two years of YouTube,
was it 2014 to 16 I wanna say.
- Or something like that? Yeah.
- Yeah, then people, people,
I think the audience,
cause I just felt like I
just got fucking bored of it.
Cause I'm just like what, what,
what what's what's cool about being angry.
I don't want to be, I
don't want to be angry.
Let me be happy, you know?
- Wow, what a controversial opinion.
I know right.
- I just want, I just want
to talk about things I like,
I don't want to, I don't want to, like,
it got to the point
where you just watched,
you just watched content and
you could tell they were,
they were like playing up
the anger for the camera.
Then they were like,
let's, let's just nitpick.
And just, let's just find
something that I'm just,
I can just like be angry
about and make jokes about,
even if I don't genuinely feel it.
Yeah, Sword Art Online.
But like, I'm kidding.
I'm kidding. That's all.
- I mean, it was true.
And that's why I don't really
make those kinds of videos
anymore either because after
a while I just realized like
there's only so much you can
do and say with that kind of
content after a while where
it just becomes like, oh,
here's, here's X YouTuber getting
angry once again about the
hundredth thing that he hates.
And it's like, all right, cool.
Anything else you can offer
to the, to the website?
No. Okay.
I'm just going to stop
watching you, you know.
- Like what are some of the best fan bases
in the anime fandom that you think of?
Cause we've talked about the worst,
- Trick question.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- I'm just kidding.
- They all are.
- Like I said, I like the BL one.
BL fans are chill as fuck.
- Honestly, BL fans seem so welcoming.
I wish more anime fandoms were like that.
- Yeah.
- I think as well, like in a
lot of senses, I think the,
the manga community, but like more so the,
the manga community that
delves more into like the more
niche titles I feel is a little
more welcoming. Cause like,
now that a lot of my content
is a lot more in that community.
I've realized that when
you mention a manga that,
no one else has heard of,
but this one person knows
that they're like, whoa, holy shit.
They fucking mentioned my favorite manga.
Yeah, I want more people to read this guy
much like the BL community. Right.
So it's like, I feel it's again,
it's like the niche communities.
I feel are definitely the most welcoming.
The nicest.
- Although I will say,
I think the BL fandom,
They just don't like
people who like Fujo Bei.
You know people who like try and like
take advantage of the whole gay thing
who don't actually give a shit
about like supporting anything like
LGBTQ.
- Obviously, if you're just, there.
- There are a lot of people
and I swear out loud,
TikTok as well, so many like people
who try and take advantage
of stuff like that.
That's about it. But I mean,
that's justified, I'd say.
Yeah, no, I, I, I, yeah.
Sorry, we went on a massive tangent then.
Cause I just fucked it up.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I think we're talking about
passion projects before.
- Yeah we were talking
about passion projects.
Yeah. To me like, yeah, go
going back to the Fate fandom.
It's it's really weird because
being like, being like, okay,
I can't like, it's so weird
saying you're a Fate fan.
Right? Cause like you say,
you're a Fate fan and,
and there are so many
different levels of Fate fans.
It's like being a martial
artist. It's like, yo,
are you a first Dan black belt Fate fan?
Or are you, oh, oh,
this guy's a fifth Dan
black belt Fate fan.
Holy fucking shit.
- Yeah but the problem is you're all,
you're all losing, right?
Your Fate fans right?
So like you don't win it all.
So why it's like the biggest loser man.
- It's really weird seeing
this dichotomy, right.
Because a lot of, a lot of Fate fans
have always been very toxic.
And I, like I acknowledge
that it is the vocal minority,
but that vocal minority is
very, very fucking vocal.
Right.
But there's such a dichotomy
between the normal Fate fans
and then just the Fate GO fans
who are just like the most
welcoming people in the world.
And like, it's, it's like they,
- Cause they want you to,
they want you to spend money,
so they feel less shame.
- Like the Fate GO fans,
they already know they're degenerates.
So just like we got
nothing to prove. Right.
And then there's, let's
just like the, like the,
I would say like it's,
it's less Fate fans.
It's like Fate GO fans
and then there's Type Moon fans. Right.
And it's, it's, it's so weird.
Like seeing that toxicity
evolve over time.
Because I remember back in the
day when I was just starting
to be an anime fan and just
discovering Fate as a whole,
Right.
They were being, they were being toxic
for completely different reasons than
they, than they,
I guess they are now because
before I remember there was,
there was like, go,
I'm talking about like
old boomer stuff now.
But I remember there was this,
there was this review on ANN
that was revealing Fate Zero.
Right?
- Yeah.
- And apparently this
guy, this guy who did,
who wrote this review, got so much hate
that he actually wrote like a blog post or
an article saying like, oh, what, like,
apparently I am watching Fate wrong.
Like people are giving him
because he watched Fate Zero
before reading the visual
novels or before like, or before
- Ain't nobody got time for that fuck off.
- Yeah.
And I guess like now I'm
getting a lot of hate because
to a lot of hardcore Type Moon fans,
it makes it seem like I'm
making it harder to get people
into Fate because I'm memeing it up.
And like, I'm like, I'm memeing
up about how many series and
how all daunting it looks for a newcomer.
- Yeah but most of those
people are being like,
why is he making it seem complicated?
I'm like fuck right off!
- Because it is complicated!
- I know and I'm just like
okay, like, as a Fate fan
I know that I don't think
it's that complicated,
but you just like have some
self-awareness to like,
look at this chart,
I'll look at this graph and
just see how's this going to
look for the average person,
you know, that's, that's like,
it's, you can try to fight the good fight
as much as you want.
But at the end of the day,
it's a daunting franchise to get into.
And that's just, that's
just something that.
- It's all perspective right?
Because again, like to the
fan, to the Fate fan base,
it doesn't look complicated
because they've literally
spent years of their life,
- Yeah.
- Studying it.
- My definition of a complicated show.
- Yeah.
If you need to watch or research
anything outside of the,
the main, like twenty-five episode run.
- Yeah.
It's considered, I consider
a complicated show.
If you have to then go and
do additional research,
- Right, but yeah, that's
the other thing, yeah.
- Literally anything that requires you to,
to go off the website and
look at something else
to understand the story
is categorized in my head
as a complicated story,
- But I feel,
- Because that's not self-contained
I can't just watch the show and be like,
I understand the Fate.
I have to look that's that's complicated.
- I feel that most majority though.
- Yeah, yeah, most people don't,
That's a lot of shows don't
require you to do that.
Think about every show
you do not, you know,
to understand Seven Deadly Sins.
You don't need to go and
read the Wiki article page to
understand what's going on.
You don't even Jojo, which has,
you know, part, part six
is a very odd ending.
You know, you can just start seven.
You might be a little confused.
But you kind of get what's happened.
Like, you know, it's inherent.
- And you can also enjoy the story
without fully understanding
it though right.
- To me, if there's any
additional reading information,
it's complicated flat out.
I don't give a shit what you think
is or isn't as complicated.
If you have to read something else,
it's complicated because they
haven't been able to fit it
into the goddamn run at the show.
- And again the whole definition of like
what a show is, you know,
how complicated a show is.
I feel it's just completely
dependent on the person, right?
Like, you know, I feel you're
speaking for the majority.
In that sense
- Yeah.
I feel like you have to think
of when you're a Fate fan,
clearly you have something
that's gone wrong where you can,
you can invest this much
time into something.
- Right.
- But a normal person will see
that and think that's absurd.
I'm not doing that.
- Yeah. I mean, it's,
this is like me as a Fate fan
commenting on what I see as
the, of the Fate community.
But like, like how as, as like
the most hardcore Jojo fans,
how'd you feel about the Jojo fandom?
- Actually, I was going to say like,
say what you will about Jojo fans
obnoxious a hundred percent.
But like I know many Jojo fans,
I can speak for about all of them,
but who are extremely hyped from anyone?
Would anyone even gives us a
shot on Netflix or whatever?
You don't give a shit If you
read the manga, it's like,
don't just get into Jojo.
Like we don't give a fuck.
- For any means necessary.
- Yeah, It's like, I don't care
if you have to play the games. I don't,
I don't care if you have to
consume it through memes,
just get into Jojo.
I feel like that is like
the numb, like Jojo fan.
That's all they care about is get into it.
I don't care how you do it.
Just don't skip parts.
If you're going to just,
- Just watch it in order
man, just watch it in order.
- Just, just don't skip parts.
- Netflix has this brilliant thing
where they play it in order, just do that.
You know? I think that's it.
Like, I, I, I could be wrong.
- Okay, okay, okay, wait.
Well there's also this thing where
- Play the devil's advocate, I don't know.
- Well, no, no, no, no.
I'm not going to say
to skip parts. I'm not,
I'm not going to do something
sacriligeous, but like,
but like there's, there's,
there's a part of me though,
is just like,
sometimes I just think a series
shouldn't get mainstream a
series shouldn't get popular. You know?
Like there are some people who
are just like, for example,
Jojo, right?
It's, it's popular as hell now.
Right. But like, part of me is just like,
I don't think Jojo should be
a mainstream series because
it's just way too weird. You know?
Like I like could, like sure.
If you skip parts, it might
be easier to get into.
But I just feel like
it's just not a series
that lends itself to being
like the fucking Marvel franchise.
You know what I mean? It's, it's just,
it's just too out there, you know,
because I feel like being
part of the Jojo fan and like
beating a fellow Jojo fan
does like, there's like,
it's like a connection there. You know,
- So you also like that
weird thing I like.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, right?
And I'm like, especially go-
- And they kiss.
- And like especi-
(all laugh)
- And then you see an unsucked dick.
- That's one of my favorite images.
I don't know why it makes me laugh.
It's like the gif of the
Hulk running in the desert.
And it's Jojo fans when
they see an unsucked cock.
(all laugh)
I don't know why, and
you know, and I love it.
It's so fun.
- It's so funny.
- Cause Jojo for me has
just become full circle
when Jojo fans just want
a clown on themselves
being Jojo fans.
Because its so, I don't know, I love it.
- There are just some captions though.
We're going on another different tangent.
There are just some captions
that just stick out in my mind
for like some gif or something.
That's one of them.
The other one is just like.
- That's why I love that its main stream.
It's just so fucking weird.
It's just like, that's
why it is main stream.
It's so fucking stupid.
- I think Jojo, just
like, I don't know why,
how it was just so head
of its time, because like,
it was made way too early
- For meme culture.
But like, it's sort of like
predicted meme culture,
not even predicted. It was
just made for meme culture.
And I like now it's getting
popular because of the memes.
Right? And I feel like you
meet a Jojo fan and you like,
I know you went through, I
know you go through part one.
You are you a real one.
You stuck through.
You had faith, man.
- You watched all 50 epi,
48 episodes of part three?
- You believed.
- Nice.
- I was bored in the middle two man.
I was bored too, but I sat through it.
- But we go through it together.
- We go through it together.
- I think something that's
not often talked about Jojo
it's the fucking there's,
there is some boring parts.
There is a lot of boring parts to Jojo.
- You know, its not a perfect show.
- I've met a lot of people who have
fell at part one and
part three, like it is,
it is a hard show to
watch at part, at times.
- Part three especially I think.
- You're rewarded
- I actually thought, I actually,
I actually thought part one
was easier to get through
than some of part three.
- Yeah. Unfortunately, you know,
I love part three to death.
Cause it's brought us some
of the most iconic parts,
but you know, as a Jojo fan,
I recognize that part three is
especially the anime is long.
It is not good at times
straight out it's I don't think
some, some fights are
entertaining as much as I love the
Orangutan and then stuff like that.
That, that fight was kind of boring.
- Like yeah.
- It ended really meh.
- It's just weird.
- I think part three needed,
was like twice as long
as it needed to be like,
the ideas were less interesting
than what you saw in like
other parts I would say.
- I'm sure people disagree. I don't care.
That's just personally how I felt.
- Because like with Jojo fans are like,
Jojo, that you only hear about
positive things about Jojo
because Jojo fans just want more people
to get into the Jojo.
The right way.
But okay, okay.
Totally off topic
though, kind of on topic.
How'd you guys feel
about gate keeping then?
- Gate keeping like shows?
- Yeah, or just gate keeping fandoms.
- In general?
- In general.
- I don't know if its just because
I've become wiser with age.
Now I don't give a shit.
- Yeah, I don't really
give a shit anymore.
- I think when I was like 18, 17,
I probably cared a bit more. I probably,
- I definitely cared, you know,
back when I was making those
like negative shoulders. Right.
But now I'm just like, if
you want to get into a dude,
just like just getting
into it. And it's like,
cause at the end of the day
you can gatekeep all you want.
But like, you know,
if people do come in and
find it and they don't end up
liking it, then it's whatever.
Like it's not, that's not gonna
make a difference for you.
- I mean, it's easier for
me to say now, you know,
my wallet is dependent on
people getting into anime.
People get an anime. I'm like, come on in,
come watch some videos about
it. You know what I mean?
I'm like, come over.
You want to find more about
some Black Butler dude?
- I got, I got the right stream.
- Come on in bro.
You know,
when you,
you get some,
you want some medication,
you want some additional shots
you come to me, you know?
- Ah, yeah.
- Now it's great.
Cause you know, odds are
that if you watch anime,
you might get into us.
So I feel like it's way easier
for us to be like, yeah,
dude, I don't give a fuck.
Yeah. Come, come watch.
- Well, I mean, but I feel
again it's, as you said,
it's because we have matured a lot,
- Yeah but also
- We've just realized like,
oh, it's kind of pointless.
At the end of the day.
- But looking back when I was 16, 17, 15,
you know,
I think at the time I was
probably defensive of it because I
was, I was probably, this was
probably all I had, you know,
that made me happy.
You know, when, when
you're, when you're 15, 16,
you don't really have
much to get happy about.
And to me it was probably a thing of,
I don't want someone in
these normies getting into it
because there's something
that I care so much about.
And I'm so knowledgeable.
- I'm, so the one that
understands this truly.
- Well yeah, you meme about
it, but I also, you know,
I feel for people who,
who tie a lot of their
self-worth to these shows.
- Yeah.
And I try and you know,
when I do talk about these
shows as much as I want to,
to not discredit them for caring about it,
I want to kind of do them
justice, but also help,
help understand that people
becoming into their show.
It's not affecting them enjoying the show.
- Oh yeah. Cause,
cause I think the thing about
gatekeeping, gatekeeping is
that I understand the
mentality of why people want to
gatekeep and why people
would do it. You know?
I understand it.
And in even some ways I
do even empathize with it.
I just like, I think I've just
like grown past it because,
because like I remember
like back in the day,
when you're an anime fan,
you met another anime fan
and there was just like,
- No, it was nuts.
there was like just
this fucking connection.
- You just kiss right away.
- Yeah. You talk about sucking dick.
Like we were just skip
straight to fucking,
- Drop those pants right now.
- Like anal sex man.
Like fucking, like what.
- It literally, especially.
- I'm like, just no, just fucking no way.
It's like that fucking,
- Bite down on the pillow,
- You know that like
fucking Sonic and Mario GIF
(group chattering)
anime fans when they made each other
in the early two thousands,
that's what he was like, man.
- Especially in like the UK
where you don't really have many avenues
to meet, anime fans, it was insane.
Like he was like, you
immediately became friends.
- Yeah. Yeah.
And then like there,
there was like so much
that you had in common
with each other because you,
you just had never met another
person that was just that
just watched anime or even knew of it.
So there was just like this
it's going to sound so cheesy,
but it was just like,
it was just like a special
bond that you had with you'd
thought you had that like
just everyone outside
just didn't have.
And then like slowly as anime
got more and more and more
popular, it just started
feeling less special.
I guess. I didn't, you know,
that sounds really pretentious,
but you know, it, it, it was
special to you because it felt,
it felt like something that only you had,
only a small group of people
that you could connect with had,
and then as that medium grew,
you found more and more people
with that maybe you didn't
vibe with as much, or you
didn't connect with as much.
And you're just like, well,
this just isn't as special anymore.
And I feel like most recently
the community that's felt this
the most probably is the
fucking VTubing community.
Cause my, my God, the
amount of gate keeping
I've seen in the Vtube, Vtubing community
is like fucking insane
when it started to blow up last year.
Oh, you're a Vtuber fan?
Name every Vtuber.
(all laugh)
- Yeah, well remember when,
I feel like there's been like waves. Like,
so I feel like first gen anime fans,
people who had to somehow bootleg it
from Japan on a VHS tape.
And the second gen is probably
your gen where you were able
to get some online,
but it was mainly through DVDs
and sharing and stuff like that.
But you were able to download some,
but I feel like I was like next gen, like,
this is where like,
my first experience was like espaniol sub
part one out of three.
That was like, that was like
the worst option for me.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- And I, I feel like, yeah, we, we,
we're definitely seeing
that with VTubers now.
And it does make it more like
less special, but I feel that,
oh, I forgot, what I was
going to fucking say, man,
I had a point that I totally forgot.
Oh my God, I'm fucking stupid.
- I mean I was gonna say that,
what the anime community
went through is basically
what the gaming community went
through 30 Years ago, right.
Like, you know, you start like
you go back in the eighties,
there were kids who were like,
oh, you play fucking video
games, you fucking weirdo.
But then when you find that
one person who was like,
you like Sonic too, I like
Sonic as well oh my god.
- And that's what, you know,
and then they kiss, right.
And like, and then as gaming got popular,
- And then they saw Mario
and they were just like,
- And then they were like oh my god!
- Oh my god!
- Oh!
- And then, you know,
like in the nineties
and early two thousands,
when gaming got more and more
popular and then, you know,
the school bully would also be like, yeah,
I played video games as
well. Did you know that?
And, and then, you know,
you would just, yeah.
And then at that point
it would be like, oh,
maybe this isn't like a special
thing anymore because now
everybody is doing it.
But then at the same time,
that's like a good thing
because now we've got so many more games
and so many more amazing
games that are just like
openly talked about with everybody.
So like at the end of the day,
you know, all those people
who are gate keeping,
like video games and stuff like that,
didn't really get anything out of it.
If anything that was stopping
the advancement of something.
- Like the thing with the
thing that I understand,
having things feel less special.
But at the end of the day,
you got to realize that to
like kind of claim this kind of
piece of media or kind
of fandom thing as yours,
it's just selfish at the end of the day.
- But they didn't make it for you.
They don't give a shit about you.
They made the show cause
they want to make money.
They don't give a fuck about you.
- Yeah exactly right?
- Why are you having
some connection to this?
I get it. You love the thing.
And you know, there is some
artistry behind it and whatnot,
but yeah, the end of the day, it's like,
you're not fucking special
and the show doesn't belong to you.
And so I feel like it's almost
ignorant to believe that you
have some ownership over
it because you, you care,
you know, like, even as
YouTubers, you know, you,
you do see people who
are like I was here first
and as a YouTuber, I'm thinking,
I don't care who was first.
I mean It's great.
- It's like cool.
- I appreciate it.
And I appreciate people
who have been watching me.
But at the end of the day, it's like,
I don't think you're any more important
than someone who just came in. You know,
the only difference is is
that you were just at the,
on the YouTube algorithm at the
right time, the right place,
you know, no one's searched
for no one typed in CDwagVA.
You know what I mean?
So it's, you know, I, to claim
some ownership over that.
- It's like you, they found you
in the same way that the person who
subscribed to you yesterday
found you mostly likely right.
- Yeah and I don't.
And I'm sure the people who
made X anime or made X movie
feel the same way where
it's like, I don't,
I don't care how you found
us as long as you watch it.
- Feel like you were just
talking about a site then.
So my, mind you were
like x anime, I was like,
- No, x anime is like, any, any anime.
- I was like X videos?
- X Hamster.
I can't hear the word X on
a word and not just think.
- The whole Trash Taste set
is falling apart as we speak.
- Do we want to take a break?
- Yeah, let's take a break.
- Let's, let's take a break
while we, while we fix the set.
- This episode is sponsored by Mac Weldon.
- You're a busy guy.
So stop thinking about what
to wear and just embrace the
radically efficient Mack
Weldon daily wear system.
The daily wear system has a
selection of clothes rooted in
smart design,
made with performance fabrics
and built to work together
from breathable t-shirts and polos
to stylish button ups and shorts,
underwear,
and beyond Mack Weldon makes
it easy for you to dress for
work, leisure, and play or
wherever the summer takes you.
- God, you're just basically
speed running life at this point.
- I know.
- My God! Talk about optimization.
- I am currently wearing
my Mac Weldon underwear.
(Joey and Garnt gasp)
- Look at that.
- Is it comfy?
- You bet your ass it is.
- How's it? How's it in the summer.
- Oh you bet it's breathable.
It's firm.
It's the right amount of underwearness.
I don't know how to describe
underwear. It's amazing.
The underwear is perfect
for any day and I love that
I don't have to think about
it any summer. Any winter.
You name it. I can wear
this underwear no problem.
- For the ultimate lazy Sunday,
their Ace Sweat shorts have
modern tailoring and pair
perfectly with their ultra
soft ultra upgraded Pima T's.
- Ooh!
- Ooh! Sounds sexy.
And for weekend travel,
both near and far they're silver knit,
polo and radius shorts are perfect.
High tech, highly packable combo.
- Highly packable combo.
You bet it is.
- So what are you waiting for?
Buy some time this summer with a
Mack Weldon daily wear system
for 20% off your first order,
visit mackweldon.com/trashtaste.
And there's a promo code, TrashTaste.
That's mackweldon.com/trashtaste,
promo code trash taste
for 20% off Mack Weldon,
radically efficient wardrobing.
Back to the episode.
- I mean,at the end of the day, Garnt,
it's hard to sit here and
be like gate keeping? Good.
- Do it.
- It's like, I feel like it's
such a dated arguement and us
being like, hey guys, gate keeping, bad.
Is like, shit gate keeping is ended.
- [Garnt] Wow.
- Yeah wow.
- Yo gate keeping been real silenced
since they dropped that
episode of Trash Taste, man.
That's all I'm saying.
- Where's the response?
- Yeah. You know, its like
what am I supposed to say?
I guess it's a good discussion to have,
and then I delve into
it, but I end of the day,
it's quite hard to just be
like, yeah, gate keeping?
Good?
- When has gate-keeping ever worked out?
- Never. Literally never.
- If things, if things get
popular, things just get popular.
I'm sorry. That's just, that's
just the end all be all.
And it's going to get, if it gets popular,
then unfortunately we have
no control over it. So.
Might as well just live with it right?
- I don't think a single fan
has any control over how
popular a show is going to get.
Especially when they
didn't make it you know.
- Yeah.
- It's like the only thing
that can kill a creation
is the creator, you know,
at the end of the day.
- Even then.
- And even then its like,
- Is there like conspiracy
theorists, gate keepers?
- What do you mean?
- Like people who like believe
in conspiracy theories?
Do they like gate keep?
Like, like, they like hide?
Like oh yeah? The millennium was fake?
How fake? Tell me about it.
You know? Oh, you're just a fake one.
You just saw it on the news, bro.
- Oh, you're a conspiracy theorist?
Name every reptilian.
- Do they like, like gate keep
the intensity of the theory?
- I remember when the anime fandom
went through a phase with like,
it was like a genuine discussion
about how to spot a fake anime fan.
Like, do you remember this Joey?
You, you must remember Joey.
He, he remembers it.
- I made a video about it.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
I think it was like the third
or fourth video I ever made
was called, like how to spot a fake otaku.
- Oh my god!
- Oh my god what a throw back!
- Well, I'm just, I'm just calling it,
calling you out today.
- Joey's been real sweaty.
- You've really like dated my content.
- Oh my God!
- And I remember thinking like, damn!
I just made some biting commentary.
- So wait, wait, wait.
How did you stop and spot a fake?
I'm genuinely curious.
- Geez.
It was like eight years ago.
- But I feel like Joey
was that stereotypical
gate keeping anime fan.
- Yeah absolutely!
Im not even going to pretend
that I wasn't that guy
because I was absolutely that guy.
But then again, I think a lot
of anitubers were back then
and I feel that it was, again,
it was those kinds of
anitubers who got watched.
- I feel like you've,
you've read the room
pretty well as time has gone on.
Like, I feel like you've
understood what to change.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Well, you know, I became an
adult at the end of the day
I realized, oh,
all this shit about like
gate keeping and you know,
hating on a show that's popular
to pose a controversial
opinion, that shits childish.
It's a lot of energy man to
get anything about this stuff.
So I'm sure it would gatekeep
if I had the energy for it.
You know what I mean?
- And you know me in real life,
I'm like the least angry person.
I don't get angry about shit very often.
- I feel like I get angry
about dumb shit in life.
I don't really get angry about stuff.
I get angry about like, oh my,
my taxi is two minutes late.
I get like fake, angry over it.
I just want to get angry about stuff,
but I'm not actually angry
about stuff. I just wanna make.
I just want to like get angry
about something to go on.
I'd be like, this pissed me off.
I'm not actually pissed off.
- Yeah, you're just saying it.
- But I just want to say,
I dunno why I like doing that.
- I think it's just part of being British.
- I think so.
- Yeah I think you're just British.
- And everyone will know
that I'm not actually angry,
but it just,
I just don't know why
I like getting worked up
into like a funny way.
- I know when you're actually angry
because you don't tell me you're angry.
- I think I actually get
angry. I'm like silent.
- Yeah that's the silent anger.
Oh, he's actually angry.
- But like I never get angry about stuff.
I like or anything like that.
Cause I'm just like, oh, all right. Okay.
Yeah. I mean, okay, cool.
- Yeah. It's to me, it's
like, if I get angry
over someone's opinion
or something like that,
which is why like, I
fucking love Trash Taste
where I'm just like,
you have a shit opinion
about food or music or gaming or whatever.
We can just be fake angry.
And that's why I love
discussing it because I love
discussing with anyone. Right.
Because you can like,
when, when I call someone,
when I say someone has
Trash Taste ha ha ha
- Trash Taste is fake.
Trash Taste is fake.
We're not actually angry at each other.
- When I say someone has Trash Taste.
You can say it with the
knowledge that you don't actually
mean it. You know?
And if someone actually
takes that seriously,
then I can be like, good.
- I think I get angry, but
the emotion isn't there.
But actually some of some
opinions you've said, if I'm like,
what the fuck?
Like I'm actually pissed off, but like,
I'm not actually like upset.
- Like, I mean, you're
not going to be like,
after the camera turns I give a,
- Yeah, I don't give a shit.
- You get a visceral
reaction where I'm just like,
I need to say something right now.
- Well, the fact that you just
don't like the bidet thing,
actually may be like
kind of angry that time.
So I'm just like, imagine
like, you know, getting to,
- It's the angriest I've been all year.
- I'm just like I can't,
like you've had this amazing opportunity
to have your ass sprayed.
And it just pissed me off that
you didn't want to anyway.
But that's totally different argument.
Yeah. I mean,
- Uh, these are flashing.
- Oh yes. Should we stop?
What the fuck is going on here?
I'm angry.
- Being fake angry.
- It is what it is.
Just be angry.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
It is what it is.
- I can't remember what
point we left off at.
- It is, what it is.
I don't know. I don't know.
Our cameras cut out.
They rather, the SD cards were full so.
- We completely lost the
point that we were on.
- Basically when I'm angry, I'm not angry.
When I'm angry, I might be angry.
- When I'm silent. I'm actually angry.
- Yeah.
- But like going back to,
cause I, like going back to like
having haters that won't
give you a content another chance.
Have you ever like
watched someone's content
said it wasn't for you,
and then for some reason
you came back years later
and you're just like,
damn, okay, this content
is actually pretty good.
- Oh yeah, I've had a few options,
like a few times where I'm been like that.
But I think it's also
because like, you know,
as you grow older,
the type of content you watch
is just going to be different.
Right. So, you know, I've had
the opposite effect as well,
where it's like, you know,
I think it's very common to be like, oh,
I used to watch this YouTuber.
I grew up and then, oh,
it's not so much for me anymore.
So you kinda grow out of it.
But I think like growing
into a channel as well,
is very much a thing
- I think, I think
that's more interesting.
Cause like you grow out, you
grow out of a lot of channels.
You know, a lot of, a lot
of content becomes dated,
you know, especially if
the creator doesn't evolve.
But what I find more interesting
is that if you find a
creator that you just think is
not for you and then you come
back years later
- Oh 100%.
- And you're just like, damn,
you're a, you're actually a cool guy.
And you make cool content.
- You know, if like 10 years ago, right.
When I was in my teens,
like you would never catch
me watching like a Tom Scott
video or a, or a Mark Rober video.
Right.
But like now I feel like I love
those channels because it's
like super interesting.
And I feel now that I have
so much more of just a base
knowledge to be able to
appreciate content like that.
Whereas, you know, again,
10 years ago I'd be like,
give me the poopoo PP
jokes, where are those?
And those don't exist
on this channel. Boring.
- I'm trying to think if
there is any YouTuber...
- I feel like the biggest example
for me was probably Felix,
where like,
especially when he like debuted
as like the Let's Play It
and the face of YouTube, I'm
just like, I'm just like,
who is this guy?
Who's this guy like
making like, you know, I,
I think he was like,
- Screaming every video.
- Screaming every video,
like fucking doing, fucking
doing ear rapes, like every,
every five seconds or whatever.
And I was like, this is
just not my kind of content.
And then like,
it's so it was so interesting
seeing his content evolve over
time and just being like, okay, he's not,
he's not even close to the
face of YouTube anymore,
at least officially.
And, and now, like, to
me, he like makes content.
That was just like,
I just started watching
him like years back,
like after he had stopped
the Let's Play phase,
because I can't remember how
long it took for him to like,
change his content for being
like of the Let's Player guy to
just being like the I'm just,
I'm just a meme guy and I'm
just going to do what I want
because that content
appealled to me way more.
And it was just really
interesting to be like, oh,
he's a way cooler guy
than I ever thought he was
when I was a kid.
And I thought, and I thought this was
the kind of content that he made.
- Yeah definitely.
I feel like during his Let's
Play era, like, you know,
he was showing a, a lot
of himself, you know,
because at the end of the day, like,
I think the best way for
Let's Players to grow
is to have that personality
that you can, you know,
- Yeah.
- Kind of attach to.
But at the same time,
like now that I know him personally,
I'm like that wasn't you.
Like that was not Felix.
- Yeah.
I feel like you become a
successful YouTuber when you stop
trying to be a YouTuber.
- Yeah.
I think the real goals
to being good YouTuber,
is to stop trying to be one,
- Yeah, yeah.
like when you just embrace just yourself,
- Who you are.
- And what you like,
you know, like he,
he makes videos on like
philosophy from time to time,
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know, even though I might not
particularly have an interest in that.
I think there is something
that is very interesting about
someone who just wants to talk
about something they like.
And once you have that base
understanding of how to make a
video entertaining,
you can then apply that to
things that your audience
probably didn't know anything about.
- Yeah.
And kind of get them interested in it,
or at least have them entertained
for four or five minutes.
You know what I mean.
- My favorite video from him
to this day is still the one that
it came completely out of left field
that he made a couple of years ago.
He just made this five minute video of him
- I know what you're about.
just spilling his love over Blame.
- Blame.
And that was that's oh my God,
that's my favorite Felix video as well.
- Because it was so just like,
it was nothing like he'd ever made before.
Like he made, you know, anime
content every now and then.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But for him to like,
he wasn't even on camera.
It was just his voice and just
pictures of panels and him
just spilling his love over this very,
very niche yet amazing manga series.
I'm like, damn dude.
Like that's the most human
I've ever heard you being.
- Honestly, like a little secret here,
but that video actually
inspired me to do more personal
videos as well. It was,
it was that single video that
just came out left field.
I was like, yo what,
what, Pewdie Pie is this?
- Where are the ear rapes?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I know right.
Because I think it was, it was that video
not only like got me
back into his content,
but also inspired me and
inspired me to change my own
content to just be like,
maybe I don't need to be
always be the ha ha funny guy.
Maybe I can make serious
content as well. Right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Ha ha funny guy? Very ha ha.
- I don't like, I think
the biggest curve ball
I've like had recently was recently,
I like got recommended a video of
Logan Paul's editor. Right?
- Right.
- Who went through his,
who basically broke down
how he edited some of
Logan Paul's newest videos.
So it was like, it was like a new,
I believe it's a new editor.
That has been around for
the more recent content,
And he broke down what he did
during the editing phase and like how
he broke down the story and narrative
and how he made certain jokes work.
And I was just like, yo, this is he,
this guy knows what he's doing. Holy shit.
He's a really good editor.
And then I watched some of
his more recent content and
obviously like separating the
man from the content he makes.
It was just really good
content. I was like,
I was like fucking blown away
that I was enjoying a Logan Paul video.
And I just genuinely thought
it was like good content.
Like, I dunno,
he doesn't upload that often
anymore because why would he,
when he's making millions
of dollars boxing,
whoever the fuck he's
going to box, but like,
- God, I wanna box someone so bad,
(Garnt laughs)
just, just for the money.
I don't even give a shit about the sport.
I just, have you seen how
much money they're making?
Fuck me.
- No, but I, I agree though,
like, you know, again,
like there was always
a for the longest time,
there was always that stigma of,
you know, like, oh, Logan,
Paul video equals bad. Right.
But again, like I feel Logan
Paul's one of those people who,
you know, to his credit
has kind of done a 180 on his content.
And has really like showed that like, oh,
someone can actually kind of mature
and like make a better person
of themselves. And you know,
like you might not be
exactly a fan of him,
but you have to respect the
fact that he has changed his
content in a lot of cases
and for a lot of people for the better.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- And this is just me, like
purely as a content creator,
appreciating when someone
makes a good content,
you can tell when someone's
making good content and I can at
least appreciate that, you know
what you do off the camera.
It's something completely
fucking different, you know?
But yeah. I mean, like going
back to the boxing thing,
is there anyone you want to box?
Sorry, you just mentioned that.
And I was just like, I need to know.
- Anyone, I should make
a tier list of YouTubers,
I think I could.
- YouTubers I could beat in a fight.
(group chattering)
- Trash Taste boxing special.
That's number one on the list, Garnt.
- Garnt.
(all laugh)
- Let's do it, let's do it.
- Only Garnt.
- Someone who can help me
get a lot of money from it.
That'd be good. Dude, why
would anyone else do it?
What the fuck?
No, they're all doing it for the money.
I'll do it for the money.
The money seemed crazy.
- The money's like the money
is actually insane, but like,
okay. Like one thing,
one thing that I'm always
struggling with as a creator,
right. Is, is the kind of
the upload schedule that
you gave yourself. Right?
Because to me,
unfortunately success
- LMAO upload schedule.
- LMAO.
- What's that?
- For me, it's like way
less than you guys. Right.
But you see a lot of YouTubers
go through this phase, right.
Where they have,
they have this very strict
upload schedule and then
they get successful doing
something else on their YouTube.
And then their upload,
you kind of noticed
that the upload schedule
for their main channel or
their original channel.
- Oh so YouTubers get
successful doing something
outside of their own channel.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Are you ever,
how much personal attachment
do you have to your own channel
that you, would you ever
be scared if it dies?
Even though you're doing
well outside of it.
I mean, we have Trash
Taste now, which is...
- Yeah I mean, obviously I
don't like failing at anything.
I'm a competitive guy.
- I wanna win in every aspect of my life.
- I don't want to fail in something.
If your YouTube channels dies,
are you a successful YouTuber?
- Well, I mean.
(co-hosts laugh)
- If your YouTube channel dies,
but was once successful were you,
are you a successful YouTuber?
- Well, it depends
- Not anymore.
- There's plenty of people who say-
- Would you say you're a failed YouTuber?
- There's plenty of people
who are still succeeding
on other platforms.
- It depends how your channel dies.
- Yeah.
- You know?
If you killed it with your
own volition and like,
because of something you did
then like, you know, maybe.
- Oh yeah, but I don't
buy the whole thing.
The algorithm fucked me over.
Fuck off.
- No, no, no, not like that.
- If someone just said,
if you're a really successful YouTuber
and one day you're just like,
"you know what, I kinda
wanna do something else."
And then you're just like, "peace out."
Then I think you can say
you're a successful YouTuber.
If you got canceled for some shit.
Maybe not.
- What if you had like a slow decline,
your videos weren't really improving.
You'd kind of stagnated, you know,
your channel kind of just fizzled out.
Were you, are you a successful YouTuber?
- I don't think in that case
that you're a failed YouTuber.
Everyone, not everyone will
peak eventually, you know,
that's just a part of life.
And that's just a part of the platform.
- It's just a matter of like,
when you think it's the right
time to end it, you know,
cause some people.
- Or some people don't even end it,
but they are you know,
they're still living pretty comfortably
and they're still getting
decent enough views
- [Joey] Yeah.
- On what they do.
It's just not nearly
the same level as what they
were doing in their peak.
- What's your definition
of a successful YouTuber?
- What's success to you Connor? (laughs)
- Money, fame?
- Pyramid. (laughs)
- Pyramid scheme.
- I don't know, just...
- Cause there's so many YouTubers now,
then I'm just like,
whatever happened to them?
- I mean, it's, you know,
it's one of those things where let's,
it's very hard to tell someone
to do the exact same thing they're doing
for half the money.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You know, it's a mentally,
it's a hard thing to do
regardless of how good the money still is.
It's very difficult to tell someone,
"Hey, just accept,
you're doing half as good
as you were last month."
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
Because that's something
that takes a toll on you.
- It does.
- Because you know
you're capable of getting what you had.
- Yeah.
- And yet how do you, you know,
cause especially if it's like
more than just one person.
If there's a team of you,
it's impossible to get the team
everyone on the team to be like,
"Yeah, dude, let's just
keep doing what we're doing
for half the money."
- Yeah. (laughs)
- You know?
Its just the reality of it.
- Do the same thing for half the paycheck.
- Cause it's stuff like,
God, I don't know,
like a Yogscast or whatever
when they were making like,
I don't know,
fucking a billion dollars
or something from Minecraft.
- Or GameGrumps.
- Yeah.
How do you,
how do you convince the
gang to stay together
when the money is going as well?
Is this, this sounds like
a prelude for Trash Taste.
(co-hosts laugh)
What if we start getting less views?
We're getting 800K views an episode.
See you guys.
Trash Taste is done.
- We're done.
- What's that Twitter page?
Where it's just like things
that have aged horribly.
It's just to just see
this clip getting posted
in like three years or something, man.
- Well no,
I feel like in terms of that,
I feel like it depends
on what you are doing.
Like if you, if you
have an insane schedule,
the likelihood is gonna be there
where you're gonna be more likely to quit.
If the money isn't as good.
If the schedule is intense.
You know Trash Taste,
We just turn up once a
week and just fucking talk.
I can't see any time soon
where this becomes a burden to my life.
I'm like, "Oh fuck, I've
gotta talk once a week."
Jesus Christ.
- Oh my God,
I've gotta talk to my best mates.
What the fuck?
- Oh my God!
- Is it worth my throat power?
- I dunno.
- I'm just trying to say that
just in case people get fucking boring.
So there's always people like,
" What? They're mentioning
groups declining."
- Well again like, okay.
So then taking that same, you know,
like hypothetical that you were saying.
Let's put that in the
case with Trash Taste.
- Trash Taste, right.
- Right.
So like, would you say-
- We gotta half the views.
- Would you say that in like,
you know,
- I wouldn't give a shit.
- However many years time,
if we were getting half or a
quarter of the views, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I just wanna talk.
I don't give a shit.
I wasn't expecting a million views anyway.
- No, true.
I don't care if you know,
I was prepared for like 100 to 50K.
- We were prepared for 100K after a year.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- We've said this many times.
- We were gonna,
at the end of the day, this is,
and it always has been a passion project.
And I just want to talk.
- Yeah.
Yeah. I've got a big mouth.
I wanna-
(co-hosts laugh)
I wanna just talk with my friends.
You know?
And I wanna have an outlet to do that.
Whether that's narcissistic,
you can judge for yourself.
I don't know.
I don't know what it is.
I dunno if I need to see
a psychiatrist about it.
I don't know.
But that was what it was for me.
It was never a business venture.
It was always.
- We never planned for this to be
as successful as our main.
- Obviously.
- If not more successful.
- Obviously if we can make good money,
we'll make good money
and we'll do what we can.
But obviously if it stops making money,
I'm not going to care.
But because I have,
I have other things that I'm doing
and I never try and put
all my eggs in one basket.
But you know,
in cases where there were channels
where people's whole
career was riding on it,
it's hard to,
I find it is hard to convince
people to stay on board when
the money is like one
third, one half, you know?
- Yeah.
- It's hard.
- Well, I think in that case,
it does like,
you do have to kind of
follow your passion right?
Because you're not going to be happy,
grinding out the same,
the same content that you've been making.
- But that really shows if
you are passionate as well.
If it does,
if it does plummet for some reason.
- Yeah exactly.
- But also again,
there has to be a question that has to be,
a question has to be answered there.
It's like, "okay, if the views did half
something has gone wrong."
- Yeah.
- Whether you like to admit it or not,
something has gone wrong.
- And it's not always the algorithm.
- Sometimes okay.
On a freak accident you know?
With the whole,
okay I'm going back to Yogscast.
it didn't even fucking know.
Yogscast is a show-
- What happened to Yogscast?
- So Yogscast is a channel
that made Minecraft videos
and they didn't really,
you know, you could blame the algorithm.
- They were a big, big group.
You could blame the algorithm.
And yeah, there was a time when
the algorithm was changing.
But if one thing has been proven,
Minecraft has been everlasting on YouTube.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
And clearly what's needed to be done
was to change the content, right?
And they didn't change the content.
So, you know, time and time again,
YouTube has proven that
it is more often than not,
not YouTube's fault.
- Yeah.
Yes if you're an animator,
you've been fucked over.
But also animation channels
are still doing well.
So you have to change what you're doing.
- I mean,
there's animation channels
that have done well because
they've adapted their kind of workflow.
- Yeah.
It's, you know,
everyone wants to
demonize YouTube and they,
they changed the algorithm and
it is what it is, you know,
at the end of the day,
as YouTubers you're on borrowed time.
- Yeah.
It's always changing.
You should have known better.
When you were getting into this.
It was always changing.
You are building a
foundation on quicksand.
You should have been
changing that foundation
as you're building this tower.
- Yeah.
Constantly.
And so I get angry when
I see these YouTubers
who complained about their
YouTube video being demonetized.
On Twitter,
they're throw a fuss that it's not being,
it's not getting the same views
and I wanna reply to them.
But we're mutuals and
we're supposed to be civil.
and I wanna just slap them and be like,
"listen, you know, what's going on.
Don't try and get your
fans to shout at YouTube.
They get enough shit you know?
- Yeah.
And there are YouTubers,
I won't name them.
But there's a lot of them who still do it.
Who constantly complain at YouTube.
It pisses me off because I'm like,
this is not YouTubes fault.
This is your fault.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
And the fact that you can't see that,
or maybe you do see it and you don't care,
Is really annoying.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
Yogscast was the channel that made,
I should go into that.
It was to talk about Yogscast
which made Minecraft videos,
and their channel started dying
because they didn't really change it up.
And it's this over like
two or three years.
So they had plenty of
time to change it up.
And more often than not,
there is a obvious factor
at play that went wrong.
- Yeah.
- Whatever that might
be, we don't do know.
- Was that the end of the point?
- Yeah.
(Garnt laughs)
- Aren't we gonna state the obvious point?
- I'm just saying with Yogscast you know,
like they just didn't change the content.
- Oh okay.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Cause the way you ended,
I was just like,
and then there was an obvious
reason why it declined.
- You ended at. (laughs)
Like you ended that sentence in a comma.
- It's so obvious, it's so obvious.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- It's so obvious that I
don't need to state it.
Name a channel, name a channel.
I'll tell you the reason,
I'm so knowledgeable about YouTube.
- Ryan Higa.
- Ryan Higa?
- Yeah.
- He just doesn't upload anymore.
What do you mean?
He just stopped uploading.
- Yeah that's true.
- Every video that Ryan did
outside of the podcast did well.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah that's true.
- When he actually tried it did well.
He just wanted to become
a Twitch streamer.
Congratulations Ryan.
You succeeded in doing
what you wanted to do.
- No exactly.
That's what I'm saying.
I still think he's a successful YouTuber.
He's not pulling the numbers of his peak,
but to me that doesn't matter.
because everyone will reach a point
where they've reached their peak.
I mean I even,
I think I've reached the
peak that I can reach
making anime content right now.
To me there's just a cap of
just purely anime content.
And I've tried for years
to break through that cap,
but I just don't think the
audience is there at the moment.
- For every 100 thousand YouTube channels,
there is one that'll get a breakout.
That does well and blows up out of the,
those channels that blow up.
There's maybe one in 10
that understands what they need to do
to change their content
and to keep evolving.
To have an everlasting
presence on the platform.
You know, people like Michael Reeves
had a few videos that blew up.
And he understood what he needed to do.
I don't know.
Maybe he did.
I don't know if he did, it
could have been sheer dumb luck.
But he was making moves and
he was making the content
and upgrading the things
in the places that needed to be upgraded.
I felt maybe Michael Reeves
didn't feel like he'd blow up.
But when I watched Michael Reeves
where he did the whole fucking,
when his whole branding,
was the laser pointer in the eye guy,
that that was how he started.
And he just blew up from there
and he kept riding the wave
and he kept doing what was right.
'Cause a lot of people
and more often than not
the channels that do die
are ones that had massive
explosions in growth.
- Yeah.
That's still what scares me actually.
- Because if you have massive growth,
something is going,
you've kind of hit the nail
on the head in so many ways,
and you probably don't understand why,
because this is just sheer luck to you.
- And the first instinct is to go,
- Keep doing the same thing,
- "I'll do that again."
- Yeah because when you first do it
and you have a steady growth.
- Yeah.
- I think all of us have
had pretty steady growth,
I'd say.
None of us have had months
where we've blown up insane amounts.
You afford the cushion
to make the mistakes
of uploading repetitive content,
realizing that's not the way to do it.
You get to slowly make all these mistakes.
- Yeah.
- And it gives you kind of
like a very nice cushion of,
I can make these mistakes and
then I can learn from them.
- It's like the buffer that you get.
- Yeah
- Because to me,
the biggest thing that
scares me when I see
like maybe an up and coming YouTuber,
or maybe like a new YouTuber
making content on the platform
is when they have one or
two videos that blow up,
And then it's a pattern I
see where you have one or two
videos that get millions
and millions of views.
And then the next video gets
like 20 K feels like I've seen
that so many times.
- Mr. Beast, right?
Mr. Beast blew up on some weird videos,
like counting tens or 100
thousand insane, 10,000 IQ bricks.
And then he just kept
building on it. He never,
he never ever repeated
something for too long. Yeah.
He repeated it a little
bit, which is fine.
You can do that. I'm not
saying don't repeat ideas,
- He deviated.
- Yeah you evolve them.
- He made like a derivitation
of the content that would do well yeah.
You know, so then he would,
he would do something
like watching Logan Paul
everyday bro for 10
hours or 24 hours. Right.
So he took what was successful
about the one video. Yeah.
- That was Jake Paul actually.
Sorry, Jake, Paul.
Wow. Fake YouTuber.
- Terrible.
- He took that. He took the
aspect that people liked,
which is watching something
for an absurd amount of time or
doing something and then
applying it to something else and
it worked. And then he realized, okay,
now I'm getting all this
success. How do I, then what's,
what's kind of the
viralocity here. What's,
what's enticing people.
It's just the insane,
absurd nature of what he's doing.
So then he decided I got to
spend a shit ton of money,
which is like the next best step.
If you can waste a ton of time,
what goes hand-in-hand with wasting time
spending too much money, the
two sides of the same coin,
like it's the same thing. And it's genius.
- He was just the master
of making content.
That was so ridiculous that
no one could emulate it. No.
- One, no one wanted to.
- No one wanted to emulate.
- I mean, watching Mr. Beast, right?
It's just, it's just like,
- It's a master class in YouTube.
And I'm just like watching Mr. Beast.
Like every time he makes
something new or makes new moves
or something, it's like,
you know, you know, when,
like you feel like you feel, you,
you feel like that side
character in anime,
that's just like, okay, this
is the genius character.
And I'm just merely the
side character in his story.
That's what I feel like
watching Mr. Beast.
- You're the side character
that has to commentate every
move he's making, right.
It's like, I can't believe
he just did that move.
What's that? I'll explain it.
- Like when, when he just like fucking
opened a burger chain, I was just like
- That's genius.
- You are fucking mad.
But that is like the most genius move
I could ever see anyone doing.
Cause no one, no one's even
close, to his a genius.
And like, I don't know, like I,
I think part of it is just
experience because like
Mr. Beast went so many years
making so many different types of content
and then he blew up like,
I think like seven years
into his YouTube career.
So he's just has a lot of
experience under his belt,
but there is just a natural genius
to some of the stuff that he does
that it's just unmatched
by every other content
creator right now. Yeah.
- And, and, you know,
God forbid, there are so many
channels out there right now
that are trying to do
something of similar taste
to what Mr.Beast is doing to
varying levels of success.
- I think we'd be lying if we
hadn't taken some kind of idea
or concept from Mr.Beast
onto our own channel.
- Of course of course.
- I mean he made spending
money a cool thing.
- Yeah, exactly.
Right. That's why many of my
titles, theres money in it.
Cause it just works. Yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
I think every YouTuber has
done at least one video where
they've tried to do something similar
to varying levels of success.
- Yeah. I mean, I mean, you,
you often you see kind of,
you see content creators,
like you see these sub content
creators come to the platform
every so often where they just like this.
So ahead of the game that
they just like completely
revolutionized the content on
a platform like Casey Neistat.
I remember when like every
vlogger tried to be Casey Neistat
because he was just at when
he first started making the
vlogs that he did, which was
just like taking, taking a day.
And instead of just making
like this Handycam vlog,
but just actually making it
kind of like a short film.
And that was just like, that
was revolutionary for the time.
And like, nobody could touch
him for the longest time.
- Because you'd have to be insane
to do what he was doing
- Yeah, oh my god!
- He only got like four hours of sleep
and he had like a family
and like, this shit was insane.
Like the amount of shit
he was doing in a day,
I felt exhausted watching.
And he has like a factory full of cameras.
And then he went and then
he went home and edited it.
And I'm like, I, I would
rather shoot myself.
Like honestly, his videos looked insane.
- Dude just like daily
vloggers just in general,
are like insane
Totally not surprised that he
got burned out and quit doing.
- Have you ever seen the film limitless?
Yeah, like I feel like,
I feel like if there's any
real life example of someone
who's discovered that
drug, it was Casey Neistat.
When he first got the flight,
when he first started
blowing up Man. Cause my God,
like it's, it's like,
it's such an example of
someone who just like,
how are you finding this
many hours in the day, man,
you are using a hundred
percent of your brain.
- Hundred percent of his brain yeah.
- You've discovered the limitless drug.
- That's insane.
I just I'm in so much respect to the dude,
but like just Jesus Christ.
- Yeah, he really set the bar high.
I get exhausted thinking
about what he was doing.
Like it's insane.
- We don't even do a 10th of what he does.
- Yeah. My God, like I've had
like these past three months,
have probably possibly been
the most busiest three months of my life.
And it's still like, it's
nothing compared to what,
whatever the that he went
through at his peak years.
- For years as well.
Okay. He's also taking a shit.
Let alone just like thinking
about doing what he's doing,
you know what I mean? Like I just,
I can't don't have energy for that Jesus.
- Like, okay, so like how long,
how long did it take you doing
work on YouTube before you
realized man, it's a, it's
fucking tiring doing videos.
I like, cause I feel like,
I feel like every YouTuber goes
through the phase where like
YouTube making videos at
some point was just easy.
It was just like, I'm getting,
I'm getting paid something.
That is my hobby.
- It's when you first make a video.
And you're like, I don't,
I don't think I liked this.
I don't think I liked this video.
And I think hate this.
- It's when you start to become
like really perfectionist
about your videos,
I feel like when you
starting off you again,
you have the honeymoon period
of like everything you make is
like, oh, that's cool.
That's fun. Let's do that.
Yeah. I enjoy that.
Yeah, let's go.
But then as you start to make
more content and as you start
to grow and you start to realize, oh,
I got to like up my quality in the content
and all my quality of
the cameras or whatever.
That's when you start to get
a little more self-reflective
on your own content. Right.
And you start to think, oh,
that video I made last
week that I was loving.
Now that look at it could have
done a little better on that.
Maybe, maybe this next
video do a lot better.
And I feel that's the point
where you start to be like, oh,
okay. Now this is like seriousness.
This is like a job now that it's like,
kind of not only is my rent
and like my living on the line
for this, for the success of this video.
But also like just my artistic
integrity of making content
now is kind of on the line.
- Artistic integrity.
- Oh yeah. I mean, you know,
not every YouTube can say
that same thing obviously.
- I feel like I don't, I
feel like I just make stuff
I like, I don't know.
- Right but you know, but at
the same time you'd be lying.
If you said that you didn't
care about how your video looked
or how it was structured.
- Well of course not, I
love making a good video.
- So I feel in a lot of ways,
like as much as you maybe don't
want to admit that is in a
sense, artistic integrity.
Like you want to make the best.
You want to make the
best shit you can make.
- Yeah. You want to make
sure you are proud of
or that you enjoy.
That's just been my philosophy.
And that's why I've never like
paid too much attention to
the algorithm and stuff like that. Maybe,
maybe seeing what kind
of content is doing well
and stuff like that.
But at the end of the day, I'd like,
it sounds like such
generic advice or whatever,
but it's kind of true in
a sense where just good,
good content is king at the
end of the day, there's some,
there's some videos that
will not perform as well
on the algorithm.
But for the most part,
if you make good content,
people are going to watch it.
And then at every so often you
get someone like Dhar Mann,
which just blows your mind
because you're just like, okay,
I don't understand.
- But that's the thing right?
- I just, okay.
Maybe, maybe I'm wrong. Maybe,
maybe my entire understanding
of this platform
has just been warped, but.
- But that's the thing
right, at the end of the day,
I think everyone is asking the question,
what is good content?
Like what the fuck does that even mean?
Right. Because like, to some
people that's Dhar Mann,
and to other people, it's a Gigguk video.
Like we don't know what is good content.
- I think Dhar Mann is. I
mean, you can't say it's bad.
It's very well produced. It's just, yeah.
I think it's just so absurd
and just the amount of views is
so absurd. Yeah.
So that's, what's just kind of crazy.
I think it's just insane to me,
the amount of views this man brings in.
- Yeah. I mean, I, I can, yeah.
I think that's the
biggest thing. Cause he,
he makes well-produced content
and it's, it's just like,
it's just not correlational
to like kind of like the views
that we're seeing on this platform.
- These videos are amazingly produced,
but the story is just fucking bizarre.
It's like a child wrote
it it's really strange.
Cause everything else was amazing.
Th these videos are shot
better than like almost
any other YouTube video.
Like it's insane.
- Yeah. I dunno.
I've always found it fascinating,
like the kind of whole question of like,
what is like a successful video,
what is like a good
successful video, right?
Because like, you know, if
you're talking about like, okay,
is a good, is good content,
one that has quality.
- Yeah.
- Right.
And then like,
how do you explain the
fucking Chonk Chart video
that has 10 million views, you know?
- Yeah that's like, that's got quality.
- I don't know what you're
talking about, Joey.
- Like on, on a, on a
traditional sense. It's not.
- Oh, it's like, it's like, you know,
like report of the week. Right?
Like, and the production
quality is terrible.
- Yeah it sucks.
- But it's like, it's
amazing because it's,
it's what made YouTube great.
- And I feel that's like a big
question that like a lot of
people who are starting
off YouTube ask, right.
It's like, you know, like
they go up to the YouTuber,
who's been on the platform for
a while and being like, okay.
So you're telling me that
in order to be successful,
I need to make good content.
Explain that. What is good content?
- To me, the content, good
content is anything that,
you know, you've taken the time
to consider every aspect of the content.
You've, you consider audio,
you consider visuals like,
you watch the report of
the week video. Yeah.
The audio quality is
professional, but you're like,
you can hear it. It sounds good enough.
It's not, it's an unpleasant.
You can watch it. It's good enough.
You know, he doesn't try
and egregiously click beta.
He doesn't chase trends. You know,
I feel like bad content to
me is someone who is just
chasing trends for the sake of it.
The clickbait is just
disgustingly egregious,
they're making X, thousands of dollars,
never considered upgrade
equipment, you know,
stuff like that. You know, if you're,
if you're a full-time YouTuber
and you're using like a USB mic,
I'm just like, what?
Bro they're like literally a hundred bucks
and the audio quality
difference is insane. Yeah.
Is no excuse in my mind. Other
than I don't want to learn.
It's too complicated.
It's not that difficult.
- Yeah.
- It's really not difficult.
- I normally notice that
the people who do trace
chase trends have like,
have like a set shelf life.
They will get massive amounts of views
for like one or two years. At most.
- Or, or you'll go to their channel.
One video will have a million views.
One we'll have a hundred K.
And it's like, it's like,
that's how you can tell,
like that's a channel where you're like.
Probably not making the
most consistent stuff.
- Or, the, your content, your,
your you're clearly just, you know,
appealing to a wider audience
that doesn't so much care about you.
- You're only as worth
as much as your worst performing video.
Yeah. Like if your,
if a video of that doesn't
get in the algorithm,
doesn't do well, but people
still show up and watch it.
That's how you can kind of tell, I guess
- That's your core fanbase.
- That's like what, you know,
the people who really would turn up then,
and that's what if you
can pull in, you know,
X amount of views that is
like a healthy amount on your
worst performing video that says a lot.
I think if you are pulling
in a million views,
then you pull in 50K,
I think something's gone
horribly wrong there.
And you're clearly you're doing
something that's not healthy
or sustainable.
- Yeah.
- And sure. You can keep trending
tracing Chen chasing Chen,
but not, sorry.
- Chasing Chen, chasing chen?
- Demon Slayer, Demons Slayer
- Chasing trends.
- Then there's also
where you see YouTubers
who start to do questionable things
because they get so
desperate for these views,
they start doing these
horrible video ideas, you know,
- Like actual just like clickbait.
- you know, some real
egregious stuff, you know,
it's like where the
prank channels, you know,
you can look at this clear
examples where they were chasing
pranks so much that it became
to the point where, okay,
- It was no longer a prank. (laughs)
- Well, yeah, they, they started,
they would do stuff like pranks
in the hood where these like
white guys would just go in like,
slap some black guys.
- Oh, I've seen them.
I mean, they would just try it.
It was, it was just like a,
trying to get shot challenge
or something like that.
- What the fuck is this?
And then they would also,
it got to the point where
every single prank
channel was paying actors.
And then there was like
kissing pregnant women prank.
And it's just like, this
is just like, what is this?
Like, this is so beyond clickbait now
where you have to get views,
you have to go into such
egregious territory, you know,
and with the family channels
where they would just put their fucking
here's my here's my child's
vasectomy for 10 million views.
You know, it's like, what is this?
This is not, this is not
something that should be YouTube.
- Child's vasectomy. (laughs)
- You know? I mean you joke, right?
But this is the, almost the extent
of what these family channels would do.
They would be like, oh yeah,
today my children are gonna
fight to see who's the strongest
10 million last one to
survive, gets Burger King.
I joke but some these channels were doing
such egregious stuff to
their children that you,
you may as well have put
that up for fucks sake.
You know what I mean? Like,
I feel like when you chase
trends and you're the kind of
person who is willing to put
morals aside to get the views
is when you really see the
worst side of YouTube come out.
And I'm not saying if you trace chends,
you're going to be doing some
horrible stuff on YouTube,
but it is, it is like a
- There's a tasteful way of doing it.
- There is a, there is an
uncomfortable similarity
to the people who start
to chase trends who
sort of start to get to
the questionable area.
And that, there's a kind of,
there's a definitely a,
a spectrum of distastefulness
as I like to call it.
And you can tell when someone's on it.
- Yeah, no, cause like, for
me, like when I think what,
when I think about what kind
of content I want to make or
what, what, what good content is?
I just, I just think
back to that, like, like,
I just think back to that,
like seed in Bakumon or
something where it's just like,
I remember like the editor of shounen jump
in that series set. Like,
it doesn't matter what you make
as long as it's interesting
like that to me,
like that to me is like what
sticks out in my mind whenever,
when, whenever anyone thinks, you know,
whatever the algorithm is,
whatever video you want to make,
it just has to be interesting
for someone, unfortunately.
And.
- We've seen the kind of like
toxic content in traditional
media, right?
Like tabloids, right?
It's like you're ruining
someone's life to get content.
- You know it's,
- Paparazzi.
It's a thing as old as time,
if someone wants it as someone
and someone's consuming it,
someone's going to make it
whether it's good or bad or not
is another question entirely, you know,
like nobody respects TMZ,
but TMZ exists because it gets views
the same as on YouTube, you know?
And these channels are gonna exist
because people are gonna watch them.
Naked Yoga exists on YouTube.
Should it? I don't know.
But it's people are watching it.
- What'd you think of drama channels?
What's what's cause I feel like.
- That's, that's a can of worms.
I feel like there's such a
fine line with drama channels
from being like acceptable
to just pure cancer. Right.
It's it's, it's, it's such a,
- I wonder who you're talking about.
It's such a, it's such a
like fine line to, to tread.
Right. I know.
- I think when it comes to drama channels,
there's the right way to do it
and there's the wrong way to do it.
- I like Scarce. Scarce is chilled.
I was about to say,
I think Scarce is a
drama channel done right.
Because he merely states the facts.
- Yeah.
- That's it like that.
And there's, I feel there
are too many drama channels
that think that they're
also commentary channels.
When I feel those are two
very different things.
Like you can be a drama
channel that like Scarce,
who just states the facts
like this is what happened.
- I don't want to hear their opinion.
- And then there are people
who are like, here's the drama.
Here's why you should be
on that person's side.
Like that's cancerous, right?
Like just, just be like,
just say what happened,
just state the fact and let the audience
make up their own mind.
I don't think there's anything
wrong with that to be honest.
- I think that's why I liked
The Right Opinion as well.
Cause at least like he, he does,
he does put his opinion in it
or like whenever he's breaking down,
whatever drama or whatever,
- But that's not the core of his video.
- That's one of the core
of his video. Right.
He's breaking down what's happening.
And he separates that
from his opinion is it's,
it's like a clear divide and
that's kind of what I liked
because he, you know,
he allows you to make up your
own minds, but then he also,
you know, he, he also
puts in his own opinion,
as well as his own perspective.
I feel like that's,
that's kind of the right
way to go about it. And,
and you know, even, even
sometimes there's, might,
there might be drama
channels that do that,
but they're also just toxic
personalities as well. Right.
- And again, like,
I feel it really does come
down to like the personality of
the presenter as well. Like if you,
if you sell yourself as this kind of like,
starting a mall, but
like toxic kind of guy
who then also gives your opinion about
a certain piece of drama
that let's be real,
you're not fucking involved
with. You just saw it.
And you're like, oh, check,
check out this fight
that's happening right now.
Let's let's root for one person, right?
That's when it becomes toxic.
But if you're just like,
here's, what's happening,
you've probably heard of it.
Here are the details
make up your own mind.
- Yeah.
- You know, it's like, I'm not involved.
I'm just the messenger.
Do it with, do it with it.
What you will then I think,
I think in a lot of ways,
that's fine.
- Yeah.
- But again, it really
just depends on like
how you present it and
how you present yourself.
- This is why I can
never be a drama channel.
Cause I would just like
overthink it so much
that I probably wouldn't
even make the video.
- There's so much drama.
How do you keep up with it?
- Exactly.
- Fucking hell.
It's gotta be exhausting.
- Yeah.
- Like I, like half the,
like 99% of the time.
I just don't give a shit.
- Honestly, one thing that like, we we've,
we've talked about toxic anime fandoms,
but I think in general,
compared to like the other
communities and the other,
other things going on in other place,
I think Anitube is like kind
of like chill and drama free.
I mean, we've, we've had like our drama,
but compared to what we've seen elsewhere,
it's been like pretty tame.
- Yeah it's pretty chilled man.
It used to not be that chilled,
but I feel like it's really chilled now.
- I feel like even when
it wasn't all that chill,
it was like still way more
chill than other places.
- It was way more contained.
I feel like it wasn't like the
other communities where like
people from other
communities would hear about.
- But the thing is with
communities, right.
And then drama is that it's, you know,
as much as people want to,
unless someone does
something really scandalous,
like really fucked and that
transcends beyond the community.
And it's just so fucked
that even like normal people were like,
whoa, you know, that's,
that's a rare circumstance.
But other than that, the drama
in the community is caused.
And in solely responsible,
as far as like the biggest
creators in the community,
if the biggest creators
making drama in a space,
then there's drama in that
space. You know what I mean?
Like if we're anime fans
that we start doing something
that's really fucked.
- We better watch ourselves then. (laughs)
- It's true, you know if
there is, if we do something
it's kind of in the
anime community, right.
It's kind of,
that would be considered not
saying that we're so big to
drama, but like what, you know,
the community is kind of almost
dictated at times by like
the biggest people in it.
And that behavior is reflected downwards.
If you get into shit and you
say a bunch of shit, yeah.
The community is going
to kind of mirror that.
- This episode is sponsored by Honey.
We all shop online,
- We do.
- And we've all seen that promo code fail
to taunt us at the checkout.
- I have.
But thanks to Honey
manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past.
- Thank God!
- Ooh!
- Honey is a free browser
extension that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies
the best one it finds
to your card.
- Ooh!
- Honey supports over 30,000
stores online that could range
from tech sites to gaming products.
Anything you can think of.
- Now that is pretty POGGERS.
(laughs)
- Imagine it you're shopping
at one of your favorite sites.
- I'm imagining it.
- When you check out the
honey button drops down,
all you have to do is click apply coupon.
- Ooh!
- Oh my God!
- Wait a few seconds.
Searching for coupons. You
can find for that site,
if honey finds a working coupon,
- Is that it?
- You'll watch the prices drop.
- That's it?
- That's it!
- Nothing else?
- Oh!
- Damn, what did you save money on Joey?
- I save money on pizza
because pizza is expensive
as hell in Japan.
- Just how much did you save Joey?
- About like 15, 20 bucks, which
is a lot considering again,
like pizza in Japan is
so goddamn expensive.
- So you just got a normally priced pizza?
- I got a normally priced pizza
- Thanks to Honey.
- When pizza is like a
luxury in this country.
Thanks to Honey. So thank you, Honey.
- Honey has found it's
over 17 million members
over $2 billion in savings.
- $2 billion!
- That's not a real amount of money.
That's one second of Jeff Bezos' income.
- If you don't already have Honey,
you could be straight up
missing out on free savings.
It's literally free and
installs in a few seconds.
And by getting it, you'll
be doing yourself a solid
and supporting this podcast.
So you can get honey for free
at joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
That's joinhoney.com/trashtaste
links in the description below.
- Thanks. So honey, for
supporting this podcast,
back to the episode.
- Circling way back earlier
on about passion projects.
- Yeah.
- Any passionate projects
you've been working on recently?
Other than the Fate one?
- I guess I don't, I kinda
don't want to talk about it,
(group chattering)
because like I talked about
the Fate video and people were
asking about me about
it for an entire year,
because like here, here's the thing.
When you're working on a
passion project, it feels great.
You're just, you just
want to talk about it.
You want to get it out and then you forget
that you have to make it as well.
(all laugh)
- Shit!
- That's literally me with
the Oyasimi Punpun video.
People have been asking,
I've been writing that shit for years now.
It's like, "when is it?
When is it coming out?"
And I'm like, "don't fucking
rush the passion. Okay."
I probably recorded
was one of my favorite,
one of my favorite videos the other day.
And it was just so fun
and it was very fun.
Everything about it was great.
I filmed it, it should be out
by the time this is airing.
Hopefully if not, I guess it's a surprise.
I filmed a video where
I worked at a gay bar.
- Oh yeah?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It was very fun. They
were just so welcoming.
Everyone was just so
chilled. It was a great time.
I almost forgot I had camera's on me.
I'm just having a great time reacting
and hanging out with
the boys. We would just,
- The lads.
- Yeah, man.
It was just, it was just so fun.
And especially in Japan, you know,
because people are very closed
off here and it was very much
just having a guy be like,
Hey, what's your Dick size?
And I was like, whoa.
- I'm glad you asked.
- Well, that's the way to break the ice.
That's something you don't
see in Japan especially.
- I've had this in Japan. I
haven't had this level of uh,
- Was he a Jojo fan?
(all laugh)
- Yes. Yes he was.
- Did he see an unsucked dick? (laughs)
- It was after I sing, I sang
(speaks foreign language)
When I first sang that.
So naturally they asked
me, what was my dick size.
- I bet its huge.
(Joey laughs)
- I can imagine it has girth to it.
It was like an otaku gay
bar and it had kareoke.
- Oh nice. In Shinjuku?
- Yeah in Shinjuku.
- So in the like gay district.
So you can just go in sing,
sing anime songs with the,
with the boys.
- Hell yeah.
That sounds amazing. It was
such a fun bar, so welcoming.
It was just great. And yeah,
I just had an amazing time and it's great.
And it's one of the videos
where I didn't really think much
about it before I filmed
it, but I was like,
this is pretty one of the most
fun videos I've ever felt.
- That's the best feeling.
- Just had drinks with
the boys. Yeah, literally.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
It's really weird actually
meeting anime fans here in Japan
because you talk to some of
them and it's almost like it's
even less popular than
it is outside of Japan.
- Well its just so normalized here.
Cause it's, it's really weird.
Cause sometimes you meet an anime fan
and you say you watch anime
as well. They get so excited.
And then they're just like,
- I though I was the only one!
- "Oh my god, what's your favorite anime?
What'd you like watching?"
And, and it's, it's so weird.
Cause it's almost being
transported back like 10 years ago,
except it's, its here in Japan.
- I think it's because you
know, in Japan, you know,
they don't have a massive
social climate, you know,
it isn't, you know,
people aren't exactly
like social to one another
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, especially otakus'.
- Yeah and I think
having a solid icebreaker
like you like anime,
you know, it makes any,
anyone comfortable who, who, if you,
if it doesn't matter who you
are, if you both like anime,
you can talk about something.
- Yeah yeah exactly.
I mean like, I feel like
in Japan where again,
people aren't very socially outgoing.
It's it's such a good icebreaker
in a very comfortable one.
And I find that, especially
when you're a foreigner as well,
people feel a lot more
comfortable talking to you because
they feel like, oh, you
like the same things as me,
even though you have a different place.
And it definitely makes
them feel more comfortable.
- I feel it's especially as well,
because unlike in the West
where like the whole like
anime community and like
otaku thing is more of like
community-based thing. Even in real life.
Here in Japan, it's very much like
a lone Wolf type of thing.
Like I feel like,
- Yeah people don't talk about it.
- Like the true, like,
like hardcore otakus here.
I mean, for one don't
really go out and socialize.
- You won't meet them.
- You actually,
you won't, they won't be outside.
Like being, like walking around,
being like, I like this
thing, do you like it too?
Like, they're not going to be like that.
They're going to stick it
to like two Chan. Right.
And talk about that passion there. Right.
Obviously, but you know,
and I feel that's why like,
especially in Japan, that's so
much more rare to come across
because for one it's like, oh,
I didn't know about this whole
other side of the community
because a lot of these otakus in Japan.
Don't really interact with
other people in that even within
the same community, let alone,
you know, across the fucking ocean.
- You're here in Japan and you, you,
you talk to a Japanese person and
even if they're not an anime fan,
they're like aware of like,
obviously of a lot of anime.
Cause we're here in Japan.
But like you meet an actual
person to watch as well,
who watches anime. And it's like,
I'm transported back to
like the early periods
of when I got into anime.
Cause I've never seen someone's face just,
I've never seen a Japanese
person's face, light up so much.
When you say you watch Jojo,
or when you say you watch some other,
like some other anime that's
maybe not Ava or One Piece,
you know? Cause those are like those,
like the two mainstream anime here
that even like non anime fans
watch. And I, I guess like,
that's just not what I
expected when I moved to Japan
because I thought, I thought
at least like, I didn't know,
because I only heard about, you know,
the otaku culture from basically
from third-hand accounts.
Right. I'd never actually
had experienced it myself.
So I didn't know that
anime fans just are still,
almost like underground here
in, in some, in some senses.
Right. And that, that just
kind of like blew my mind.
- Yeah I mean, I feel
maybe within like the past,
like say 10, 20 years,
like much like the West. Right.
I feel it's become a little
bit more open and accepting and
like, you know, you know,
like even in the West,
right kids 10, 20 years ago
would get bullied for watching anime.
Now you get bullied
for not watching anime.
I feel in Japan, it's kind
of become the same thing now,
except still at the end of
the day, like the true like,
hardcore or otakus are
still very much underground
because I think, I think
they're scared to come out.
- Yeah.
- But I feel like, you know,
you said that they're
underground, but you know,
like every time you watched a documentary,
anything about Japan and otakus,
you always saw the hardcore.
- Yeah.
- They'd be like, this is, this is Tanaka.
He spent $10,000 this year on love life.
- Yeah.
- And it's like,
all right, great.
- Yes. But I think as well as well,
because like just the term or
otaku in Japan is just so much
more than someone who likes anime.
Like you have like train otakus
you have military otakus,
like just the types of fans
and like hardcore fans that you
wouldn't really see outside of Japan.
- I saw a hardcore America otaku,
- Oh did you actually?
- At my train station and
this guy was wearing a full,
what does it bald eagles?
What's it called? What's
the American eagle?
- Bald eagle.
- Bald eagle right?
- Bald eagle shirt, a cowboy hat,
like a 10 gallon one. He had
the pins of America on it.
He was wearing the bluest
denim jeans I've ever seen.
And he was wearing cowboy boots
- Nice!
- And he was just Japanese
and like was wearing glasses.
And I was like, this is just so bizarre.
It was just at my train station.
- That's some drip right?
- And he was doing the, like
the fucking hands in belt
waiting for the train to come.
And I was like, what the fuck man?
- That's so cool.
- I wanted to be like Ko Nee
Chi Wa to him, I was just like,
this is so bizarre. I was like,
I want to know the background. I was like,
I want that guy to come on Trash Taste.
Like I wanna know this dudes story.
- I don't know. It's just like,
cause like, especially like,
you know, every now and then
when you go to like a
train station in Japan,
especially like, like the shinkansen,
the bullet trains, you
sometimes see, you know,
some train or otakus
- Oh yeah and they're
always taking pictures.
- Oh yeah.
- They're always taking pictures
with these like massive
like bird watching lenses.
- People do that in the
UK though, as well as big,
big train spotting or whatever,
and the planes and you'll
see them at the airport.
- Yeah.
- But like,
I always find like that side
of the otaku fan base to be
just so much more interesting.
I feel that maybe it's because
I had known nothing about it,
but also at the same time, it's like,
it feels so much more like
mysterious because you almost
never see those kinds
of people interacting
even within the same community.
- Yeah but you also,
you also see a lot more
shows made about our otakus,
the traditional otakus,
I guess, for the anime.
Cause it's just like,
oh, look at this guy.
He spends 20 grand a month
on some P and G. Yeah.
It's a lot easier to get it.
- It's a lot weirder.
- Yeah. That's the thing, right?
Is that they want to,
these film cruisers want something weird.
it's really hard to just make fun of a guy
who just likes trains.
You know what I mean?
- That's true, that's true.
It's like, you know,
you say what you will,
but a lot of the time,
these documentaries that would
just would go into a dude's
house and be like, wow, look
at him, look at the state.
And he's got all these anime figures
they're trying to make fun of it. Really.
- I, I, cause I feel like there's such a,
such a big divide between
maybe like say anime.
And then the otaku Anime,
you know what I mean?
Basically like if, if you see if,
if you see your series and
like Akihabara or something,
then it's probably going to be
looked down upon by a lot of
people in Japan. Because I remember we,
we hung out with our friends,
a girlfriend and she was like a mad,
like a mad otaku.
I remember talking to her
and she was like, yeah,
I got bullied in school for liking anime.
I'm just like, what?
You're Japanese? What,
how, how is this a thing?
- Yeah. I think it's,
it's so common that it's almost
cool to not like it and do
something else. Right?
Yeah. But I dunno like the whole, okay.
When, when someone, all right, this is,
this is a controversial take.
When someone is like severely
into something like a show,
you know, I was about to
describe myself there.
Actually.
I was like, cause you know, you see these,
you see these things where
like they make their whole life
about something, right.
This is me with Jojo innit?
- Yeah. It really is.
- I saw something, you know,
when I remember that I'm watching
the show one time and this
woman had like, everything
in our life was Barbie.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. The
one living in LA right?
The Japanese woman
- That's right. Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, I've seen that.
- Everything she owned was
Barbie. And I was like,
is this like something that
like can happen to anyone
or is it something that like...
- He said, he, he ponders, while,
his Jojo posters are in the background
with the Jojo statues.
- Listen I love-
- And the $10000 Jojo merch.
- Everything he says is Jojo words.
- And the $10000 Jojo suit.-
- Listen, I love Jojo
But I don't feel like
because when I see them talk
about their show, I don't,
I don't feel like they talk about it
the way I feel about Jojo.
You know what I mean?
- That's what, every one of those like
obsessive collectors think as well.
- Talk to Connor in 10 years.
- Here'a my Jojo toilet.
- This can be just taken out of context
and just clipped with me talking
about Jojo, I realize that.
But like when I see them,
there's almost like this, like,
like this obsession that feels unhealthy,
or you could probably say that you could,
probably accused me of being the same.
- Yeah.
- But you know, we're
not, we're not, I just,
I just liked the style
and I like decorated my
office in a certain way.
Outside of that none of my
rooms are Jojo, you know?
Or there's nothing else.
- Are you talking about like,
when someone's entire house,
is like.
- Their entire existence becomes
a collection of this thing.
And I just wonder I'm like,
is that something that
just happens to anyone
- I think so.
- Or is it that,
or is it something that maybe
something's happened to you
where you, you know,
you've had an experience or
maybe you've been raised in a
certain way and that,
that makes you more receptive
to being obsessed with something?
What do you think?
- I'm sure both sides can happen,
but I think,
- Psychiatrists,
Psychologists in the chat,
can you let me know?
- I think at the end of the
day, it's just about like,
how much do you like this
certain thing, right?
How much are you willing to sacrifice?
- I don't know?
A part of me thinks there has
to be something where you have
to be more susceptible
to addictive tendencies.
- I also think there's just
some people where for whatever
reason in their life,
there's this one thing means
so much to them personally.
Maybe it came along at the right time.
Maybe it helped them through something,
but like they are so personally
attached to this thing.
- I'm not trying to bash it by
the way. I just want to like,
actually discuss it.
- I think, I think that's the real reason.
Cause I mean,
I feel like a lot of idol
fans fall into that category
where, where, you know, they,
they want to support these
idols because they gave them
something, you know?
- Yeah, yeah.
And I, I, I feel like
that's more likely, I mean,
I'm sure there are a lot of
people who maybe have addictive
tendencies as well.
- Right? Yeah.
I guess because the whole
thing that sucks about talking
with idol staff specifically
is that, you know,
here in Japan, I mean,
there was just some stuff that's fucked.
Like, you know, there was this one,
- I mean the idol industry in general.
- It's okay. Well, yeah,
there's so much predatory
shit that goes on in that.
I can't remember if I've talked
about this on Trash Taste,
but was just one video on
YouTube done by some that I wish
news agency was there. Some
not super mainstream one,
they did like a documentary
with this British guy and he
just goes to idol stuff,
but not normal idol stuff.
13 year old idols in Japan and man,
this is an uncomfortable watch.
Cause it is like these dudes
go to these concerts with this
13 year old girl. Yeah.
And she's dancing and stuff.
And the guy goes around,
just ask these guys like,
"Hey, why do you like it?"
And that the answers they
give are just really like
uncomfortable. If they don't say it,
they don't say what you,
you know what I'm thinking,
but they don't really give
a good argument as to not.
- There's actually, there's a
really good documentary I saw,
I think it's on Netflix
called Tokyo Idols.
- I've seen that one.
- I watched that one.
- Yeah. But that one wasn't that bad.
Cause I really liked that one
because I felt like it wasn't
an insulting look into it.
- Actual like in-depth
look, but at the same time.
- It was tryna give a, I
would say an unbiased look.
- Yeah. I think that was just interesting.
I watched it. I'd like you
watch it and you don't,
you don't really want to,
you don't judge any of the
people there. It's just like,
to me, it was just fascinating.
How, how someone ends up
in this situation where he,
you know, they spend
thousands and thousands of.
- Yeah, if you wanna give,
if you're a 40 year old man,
and you want to give thousands
of dollars to a 20 year old
woman, that's fine by me.
Yeah. I have no qualms about that.
You know, you can do that.
That, that's your, that's your money.
You do what you want with it. Yeah.
But like the one where it was
like 13, I was like, come on,
come on. I mean, I
haven't seen that video.
I've sent you a link later.
It's just like, oh my God dude.
And it's just like,
it's so obvious what's going on
- Yeah it's not a good look.
This is one of those things
where it's like some idol guy
was like, man,
these guys are making so
much one of these idols
child idols. And it's like, no, no.
- No, no.
Oh my God.
- Yeah. I mean like, even if
you don't mean it in that way,
that everyone's thinking
like, it's, it doesn't help.
It really is not a good
look. I feel, yeah.
- Like, especially living in Japan,
I feel like Japan as a country,
more than like any other country
that I've seen or been to,
like, I understand the word otaku here,
because there are so many like
really obscure things that
people just get obsessed with.
And like it's, it's, it's,
there's no like definite pattern in it.
But like we talked about anime otakus,
but that's like the most,
I'd say the most broad
otaku there is in Japan.
Cause you meet, you meet
people who are obsessed with
like really strange things.
- That's almost the most normal otaku.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it is right.
- I think so. Cause like,
when you look at my strange addiction,
you look at these lines,
Sandy eating our otakus,
the animals.
That's why it comes to, I
try, it comes to my mind.
Cause I feel like somebody
who eats the stuffing in their
mattress, which is a
real thing, by the way I,
I assumed I assumed TLC is a
hundred percent rock solid with
their journalism and this is an accurate,
I'm sure some of the stuff on TLC staged,
- Some.
- Probably most of it. But you know,
people that do the weird
thing where they like
eat only fries.
- Yeah.
I feel like that's,
that's gotta be some sort of
similarity to somebody who was
obsessed with a certain thing
that dominates their whole life.
- There's a big difference
between an obsession
and an addiction.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. I feel, I feel like, you know,
when you are something is your identity.
It is an addiction. In some senses,
I feel like obsession,
addiction, the lines blurred.
- Do you have an addiction to Jojo?
- This is some intervention.
(co-hosts laugh)
- Is it a, let's make it clear.
Is it an addiction or an obsession?
- I, I am obsessed with the style of Jojo.
(co-hosts laugh)
I'm not addicted to Jo, I don't.
- That sounds like denial.
- Day by day. I don't think about Jojo.
I don't do anything to do with Jojo.
- Really, your actions says otherwise.
- I can, I can not watch
Jojo. I don't have to-
- I can quit anytime I like.
(Joey laughs)
Listen. I don't suck every day.
(co-hosts laugh)
- You're not looking for
the next unsucked cock.
- Where is it?
(co-hosts laugh)
- I can , I don't think
about Jojo most days. Right?
I know this sounds like a meme!
Right?
(Garnt guffaws)
- This sounds like a meme.
I don't think about it most days.
I just, I love the style.
I love it in my room and the
suits of banging straight up
fire, you can't deny.
But even if you don't like
Jojo, those suits of fire,
you know what I mean?
- Right
- Yeah.
- If the suit looked like shit,
I wouldn't buy it, but it looks fire.
- No it does. I'm not,
I'm not denying that.
- I'm not denying that.
- Now that being said,
if I suddenly became just
everything about my life was Jojo.
I only ever wore Jojo things.
I wouldn't stop talking about Jojo.
And garnt I know what you're going to say.
There was a phase in my life where I,
I did only talk about Jojo.
That was a short period.
When I got into it, I'm not proud of it.
I've changed for the better intervention
Garnt told me to stop. I did.
- I'm a changed man.
- If only every Jojo fan could be.
- But also at the same time,
I think I'm like, okay,
I see these people who have
these very severe addictions or
something. And I think, okay,
maybe something has gone
wrong. Maybe it hasn't.
But at the end of the
day, I don't really care.
You, you seem happy.
You're not hurting
anyone. Do what you want.
That's how I ultimately,
that's what it comes down to.
But I am just fascinated with
how one becomes addicted to
something like that. Severely.
You know what I mean? I'm
not trying to bash on it.
I want to make that clear.
I'm not trying to say,
oh, it's fucked up or anything.
I just want to know the process
- Yeah, because its facinating.
- I feel like because it's
not a super normal thing
to do because it's not
something that happens every day
to everyone.
What happens to make someone
super addicted to something?
I just want to know.
- My strange addiction.
- Science explain!
Yeah, its always about
the strange addiction.
not how it became my strange addiction.
That's what I wanna know.
- I just think like, especially in Japan,
it's part of the reason
why Japan is such a
goldmine for content, right?
It's just because kind of,
kind of like so many people
are so many are into so many niche things.
- Because when you,
when you make people have to
become so goddamn normal and so
assimilated in society,
- Yeah.
- Anyone is dying to do
anything different. Yeah.
That's why we get so many,
these niche and crazy.
- Oh, there's so many like
niche bars and places, which,
you know, some, some you've been through,
some are still out there
probably like we were
- Never to be found.
- Cause their entire childhood,
their creativity is snuffed out.
We don't get to be creative.
So they become an adult and
they can make money and they can
live that life. You know? Finally.
- It's that epiphany moment I'm like.
- Yeah they can take control.
- I can be different.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
I think that's part of like
the part of the interest
thing about living in Japan
is you walk down the street
somewhere and you just,
you find this random place
and you're like, what?
Who made this? What like?
- Only in Japan.
- a lot of things are only in Japan.
- Living here,
you just become to have such
an appreciation for people here
really do. Just,
don't give a shit
and love what they want
here because my God,
life is hard here. If you don't conform,
if you don't do what
everyone else is doing,
you're the one sticking out.
And so when I saw that,
that guy rocking all,
he was American attire. I
thought, man, the balls on this,
man, thank God.
Thank God.
He had a good pair of denim
jeans to contain those,
those giant balls, you know,
keep rocked up to a Japanese
train station wearing that.
But that man did not give a
single fuck what people thought.
And it makes you kind of happy.
Cause you were like this
man doesn't give a fuck.
What anyone else thinks?
- My, my mind Japan.
It's funny. Cause every like,
since moving to Japan and living in Japan,
my standard for what's become
cool and bad-ass has just
become so much so warped compared
to like when I was living
what I was living elsewhere,
because I remember this,
I remember this one time, it was like,
I was like a busy street
in like Shinjuku. Right.
And we were,
we were all just like standing
there waiting for the lights
to change.
Then one guy I I'm walking
right behind this one guy and,
and he's walking towards his
massive crowds and like the
lights are still red. Doesn't even flinch.
Doesn't even stop just
walks and J and J walks.
And I'm just like what a bad-ass.
(all laugh)
- Yeah. The emotion, the emotion that I,
and this is gonna be a
hundred percent accurate.
But you know, at the end
of Shawshank redemption,
when a Dufresne finally breaks
free. That's how it feels.
Never a Japanese man. Doesn't
conform the son of a bitch,
This son of a bitch crawled through
the mile long pile of shit to do it.
Goddamn!
- I'm like he saw the red
light that says not walks.
And he, it didn't, he
didn't even phase him.
He said, this.
He said, "fuck the system."
I'm just like, fuck me, man.
That's a bad-ass. And I'm just like, my,
my for bad-ass is so warped
living here because you see that
I think, and then I'm just
like, oh, it's just another guy.
- That's the key to living in
Japan is to live in Japan and
get all the good things
and not anyone off. Yeah.
We're not saying.
- To break the rules of Japan, do that.
- Do whatever the you want.
Like as long as you're not
hurting anyone and you're not
breaking any rules, do what you want.
Yeah. Japan is such a depressing place.
If you follow every single money rule,
it doesn't need to be following.
- Yeah. But that's the thing.
Right. And, and I feel,
that's why Japan is one of
those few countries that does
birth, some of the,
the craziest looking and the
craziest acting and just like
the most like unique type of people,
because you need to be like
that in order to feel like
you're living sometimes.
- Because it seems like it's
either one way or the other,
it's such a, it's such an extreme.
Right. Which is why like,
whenever I like Japan is
famous for having like very low
crime rates. Right.
But for some reason,
whenever you hear about a
crime being committed here,
it's the most,
- it's a fucking crime!
- It's the most fucked up,
demented I've ever heard.
Like what the fuck?
- Yeah.
It's like the other day it happened right
on the Odakyu line.
Those are the guy who like went on
and just like stabbed 10 people.
Cause he was like, I
just wanted to I'm like.
- He's like the women are happy. Right.
- I want it to stop happy
women. I'm like what?
- Like just, just rob a,
like hold up a corner
shop or something, man.
Like someone like holding
up like a corner shop.
- Steal grandma's purse, you
know like something simple.
- I just said,
there's just so many people
who were like idolize Japan in
that way. And I think, you know,
you have to be realistic about it.
Like I remember I socialized
with Chris and there was this,
he was on Facebook reading
an article or something.
It was a post someone made
on Facebook. It's like,
did you know,
Japan has the least amount
of exams in the world.
And I was like, yeah, but
only for a specific age group.
And then they fuck them
to death with exams.
They had already ruined their life.
They don't get to do anything
other than examine study.
Like it's like, oh great, great.
They get to have one year where
they get to run around the
fields and have fun. And
then we fuck them today.
It's you know,
the amount of pressure on
people to succeed in exams here.
I don't know anyone who went
to a cram school in the UK.
Are you kidding me? I
wouldn't even have cramps.
I'm sure there is on I
don't know where it is.
I don't know anyone
else who went into one.
At most people had like a private tutor
once a week or something like that.
- And even then it was like,
"wow, you have a private tutor".
- Yeah like education
not good enough for you?
Like five days of school.
Not enough for you.
Huh?
- I say that as I went to Saturday school.
- You know,
there's a lot of harsh
realities about Japan that is
overlooked because we
want it to be this rosy
and beautiful place that is.
- Which it is.
- In a lot of aspects it is yeah.
- I feel like we're looking
where we're lucky enough to not
have to be part of the Japanese system.
- We avoid the probably
some of the worst aspects
of working in Japan.
- Yeah.
- I think we work in Japan in
the most comfortable way ever.
- Yeah, we're working right now.
I can just sit on my ivory tower,
looking down all these
peasants and telling them, oh,
you should stop doing that.
You should try working from home.
Have you heard of that?
Its the new hip thing with
the young people right now.
- Wasn't there a thing where
they wanted to get people to
come back into work and
like a little bit of work.
It's like, please, God, no,
we want to keep teleworking.
- We've discovered the
beauty that is teleworking.
- I feel like if anyone was
going to love teleworking
it going to Japan. Oh my God.
- It's like kind of like mind blowing,
that it's taken this long for
them to adopt it honestly.
- Have you been on a Japanese Zoom call?
- Yeah. Unfortunately.
Oh my God. If you've been on one?
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
I was like, whoa, where's the fun guys.
Come on, talk a little bit.
Like no one said anything.
I got on the call we were
there for like five minutes.
No one said anything because
they were waiting for one more
person. We're all just standing
there with our cameras on.
I was like, ah, so the summer, right?
- Am I in the right place?
- I'm like, please, please I'm not,
I'm just like please someone
talk about the weather. Just,
just, just, just talk
about the weather please.
- It's been basic as fuck but.
- I was just waiting
for my turn to go on a
game show or something like
everyone was just nervous.
Like no one said anything. And
then even then it was like,
everyone would like, some
of them would say something.
I don't know.
I've been on zoom calls with
like Americans in so much more
chill obviously. Cause
I'm picking out whatever.
But I remember there was one
call I had and there was five
of us and one person would say
something and they would just
wait like 30 seconds, like process it.
And they would be like, and
- I'd be like, guys, this
is, this, isn't a courtroom.
This is a fucking zoom call.
I saw, you know, they would in America,
they would publish some of the,
a lot of the Zoom court proceedings.
And I said, that was, that was more,
more jovial fun going on in
those then on these zoom calls
that I was having, I
would just stand there.
- What do you mean like jovial?
- Like more fun having more fun.
- The judge is like guilty JK.
- and just a few,
few jokes cracked here
and there a few, you know,
even the judge would be
like, how's the day going?
Hi. Good, good, good.
Anyway, this is far proceeding number.
- Anyway life.
I just thought I used the
weirdest thing that they was just
like this weird understanding
that no one was allowed to
talk until everybody got on the zoom call,
but no early
- Because its all about procedure here.
If its not according to procedure,
then it's just chaos and panic.
I was just like, this is the,
this is the most like
unfun Zoom call of my life.
Not Zoom calls are fun.
- Not that expect them to be fun,
but I didn't expect it to be
I'm waiting for my hostage
person to tell my family about
how much they're going to ask for ransom.
- I'm waiting for the
godfather to enter the room.
- Yeah It felt like something like
there was some kind of like
spiritual ritual about to take place.
It was so strange.
- Like a seance. (laughs)
- I was like, what is this?
- Right. Anyway, I think that's
a good place to wrap it up.
- What a good episode.
- what a good episode.
I like how we talked
about toxic clickbaits.
But as the title you probably
read was complete clickbait.
We don't hate our fans.
And can you go,
can you believe that Trash
Taste made some toxic clickbait?
- Toxic clickbait that I wanted not to do.
- We did it to prove a point.
That's what we all were telling ourselves.
We just wanna prove a point.
- Joey do do the fucking Patreon
shout-out thingy-ma-bobby.
- Okay we'll do the patron show.
- Look at all the patrons though. Amazing.
They fell for the click,
but it's all right.
They still support us because
they're on our Patreon.
And if you can, if you don't
care about our clickbaity ass,
then make sure to go over to our
patreon.com/trashtaste
- Great outro.
- to subscribe.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send us the means on the subreddit.
And if you hurt our face,
listen to us on Spotify subscriber.
- Subscribe.
That's been another
episode of trash tastes.
We love our fans.
I love you beautiful bastards.
Jojo fans please stop sucking Dick.
Stop. Stop, please.
Sucking Dick. Not all dicks
need to be sucked in the world.
- Jojo fans like what?
Impossible!
(all laugh)
- I feel attacked.
- And we'll see you guys next time.
- [All] Bye bye.
(outro music plays)